Oh!
Hello?
There we go.
Welcome back!
Hello?
Everybody.
Oh, I'm tired.
Right before this I played Pika Park.
And boy are my arms tired.
Oh.
I thought it was like a loop.
It is not.
A loop.
Yes!
If you didn't see that, I did not stream my POV.
You can check it out on DokiBird's channel.
She streamed it.
I don't know who else streamed it actually.
But um...
It's not a loop, it's a spiral.
Into madness?
Oh my goodness.
Yes.
Into madness!
We're spiraling!
Lime, Bao, Amelie, Snuffly.
Oh, for everybody else that streamed it?
There you go.
Yeah.
I figured since I was gonna...
I planned on doing this...
Well, actually...
Well, I wasn't sure what to do today.
But I was like, I wanna play a spooky game.
Cause it's Halloween!
It's Halloween!
I have to play...
At least one...
Or two...
Maybe three spooky games a week.
Until Halloween.
Yay!
But uh, today...
We're playing...
The Bath House.
Jigoku Sentou.
R-Ri...
The...
Redo.
Apparently, I guess...
The game broke?
And...
It's okay if I share something for you.
Wait, what do you mean by that nod?
I'm scared.
What do you mean by that?
We were all...
Busy yesterday with V-Day and 3.0 hype.
We didn't have the chance to say welcome back from Japan.
Hope you had a good trip home.
Thank you!
Oh, is it okay if I talk a little bit?
Except...
I don't wanna talk with like, this...
Bathroom sound...
Behind me.
Maybe I should start the game and then talk.
I feel like I didn't get to tell any of my stories either.
Maybe we should yap for a bit.
Before we start the game.
Happy 3rd of Halloween.
Yeah!
Oh!
It's not!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
I think Pico Park is considered psychological horror.
So true.
Happy birthday.
Yeah.
I wish a dream come true.
I hope we would really fly even further to the blue skies like a plane.
You're pretty good buddy.
Thank you so much Dan.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
I was reading through messages yesterday.
It's from Super Chats and stuff.
So...
After stream and everything.
Thank you!
How much time...
Oh, time.
How much I could do for your birthday this year.
Contacted one of my artists and they published my $200.
$200!
Hashtag onlyfandomcommissionedforfree.
Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
Thank you very much.
It's time for late birthday greetings.
I can't read at all.
Oh my goodness, I'm just inserting words everywhere.
Send me your spooky super chat for my spooky birthday!
Your spooky birthday?
Today?
My spooky birthday yesterday?
Not yesterday.
The day before yesterday.
It's my Oshii's birthday two days ago.
Could you sign happy birthday for me?
Spank, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Kurustoke, let's go!
Yeah, they had to redo the whole story and everything for this, apparently.
I didn't even know that the game broke.
And Rainbow, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Uh...
Yeah, and they had to remake the whole game.
So I'm excited.
It's actually been quite a while since I played the first bathhouse.
I don't remember so much about it, to be honest.
I don't remember... well, I remember some things about it.
I don't remember what the story was, so...
So it's a remake slash remaster.
I guess... kind of.
I'll double tap this just like Snake would.
I need to beat the runs, you big baby.
What do you mean?
What does this... what does... what does that even mean?
What did that mean?
Andragos, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
I gave one gifted yesterday to agree with Matara that you're stinky.
I appreciate it.
Don't give in to Matara's lies.
You know what smells?
A bug.
You know what doesn't smell?
A person.
Or a ghost named Mint.
That smells fresh, right?
Just the... you know, you're just like...
You have the idea of... of a ghost and also minty freshness.
And you're like, ah, there's no way that could smell.
But a bug?
There's literal stink bugs.
It's like in the name.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Yeah.
There's no way that I could smell.
Or be stinky.
Maybe in personality.
Like, happy birthday, first talent, Pinto.
Thank you!
Let me know if the water sounds gets annoying, you know?
Just let me know while I'm talking.
Thank you!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
If you don't stink, why the bathhouse?
Well, this is how we, you know, maintain our freshness.
By always going to the bathhouse.
Let's try 500 times.
Thank you!
Birthday dinner funds.
Oh my gosh, dad, please, stop donating!
Prayback, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Speedy fire, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Roaches have an incredible sense of smell.
They do?
I don't think so.
I only show up when they're stink.
Saku, didn't you say you were going to be gone for a while?
What is up with this?
Tika, thanks for the 10 gifted!
It's haunted because, you know what?
Someone broke the no-soap rule.
What's that?
Don't worry, I live.
Stop.
Oh my...
Oh, the no-soap-on-the-mountain rule!
Yeah, probably.
If you bring soap onto the mountain, you get stoned.
Ashen, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Oh my goodness, I feel like I'm just saying thank you over and over and over again.
I just finished a meeting.
I was getting ready to clock out, brat.
Yeah, so my Japan trip.
I think I...
I did a Twitter space.
Which should still be up, I believe.
That I talked about TGS.
I saw...
An Oshie I haven't seen in a long, long time.
Four years.
That I haven't seen her.
And she still remembered me.
I was really happy.
She like, saw me.
And she like, yelled my name.
And like...
And she's not...
She's not like, active anymore, right?
She like, retired, essentially.
So, there's not even a way for me to talk to her.
She wouldn't remember my name or anything.
Alright, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 5th day gifted!
Thank you!
Very, very kind of you.
But...
I was really happy to see her.
Because...
I...
I have a cheki album.
She's actually the idol that I have the most chekis with out of anybody.
I loved her like...
Like, almost no one else.
I don't...
I don't call her my Kamioshi, because at the time I had a Kamioshi, but she had just recently...
Graduated and retired.
So...
I was kind of in like an in-between phase, but if I wasn't in that in-between phase, she would definitely be my Kamiyoshi.
And I have a checky book that's entirely filled with her.
Like, just... only... actually, it's overflowing now.
Because I got more checkies with her.
I got more pictures with her, so... with this chance.
So, were we talking about an idol that I really love?
She's been gone for a couple of years.
And so... the rebound?
Oh, she...
She wasn't, though.
Because she also was into that same idol that retired.
And it was one of the first things that kind of... like, made me like her.
Because I was like, oh, if you like this idol, you have good taste.
And so I was just like, I will follow you.
And then, like, her...
Her... just personality.
She's literally one of the most unique idols I've ever... have ever, ever met.
Ever!
And the fact that she's not an idol anymore is just such a loss to the industry.
She is actually just so insanely unique.
And I just love her so much for that.
And... uh... um...
If I... maybe one day I'll post, like, one of her checkies.
Because her handwriting is just absolutely impossible to read.
What makes her unique?
She's... just actually just really wacky.
She had, like, a bouquet.
Oh my gosh.
Her checkie line took two hours.
Just because she was talking... she had... she's not with a company anymore.
So she had no limiters.
And so she was just talking to everyone for, like, five, ten minutes.
She was just going off.
She had a bouquet of flowers and she would shove them in people's faces during their pictures and stuff.
Who are we talking about?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry if people are coming in.
I'm talking about an idol that I met.
That I... one of my Oshis that I haven't met in four years.
So... yeah.
She... I just love her so much.
I love her so, so much.
Oh!
There it is now!
Thank you!
Bring it... wait.
Let me bring it back to you.
YouTube doesn't allow me to do $500 for some reason.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
My goodness.
But yeah.
It was so great seeing her.
I actually didn't cry in front of her.
I thought I would.
I really thought I was gonna cry.
Because I kept tearing up in line.
But I think because I waited so long.
It all like sucked up back into my...
Into my spirit.
Real recognizes real.
And...
But yeah.
It was such... I'm so...
I know I took off a lot of time recently but...
Thank you guys for being patient with me and letting me go.
And...
Thanks to the tiny gifted.
And then I also watched my...
Other Oshii graduate.
And...
It was so sweet.
I cried a lot in front of her.
And...
I like... It was so sad.
I like get up to her.
And I sit down.
And I had like this whole speech prepared in my head.
And then she just goes...
She like...
You know...
Yells my name out.
And she's just like...
I waited for you.
And I just look at her.
And instead of speaking I just go...
That's the noise I make.
I go...
And then she goes...
And then she realizes I'm crying.
And...
And she like...
Starts talking for me.
And...
It was an immediate choke.
She starts talking for me.
And...
Um...
Sorry.
I'm sad.
Maybe I shouldn't have talked about it.
Um...
She just kind of was like...
Uh...
She was just like...
Come back to Japan.
Basically.
And like...
When I was...
Uh...
It was my...
It was very short.
That we...
We didn't have a lot of time to talk.
Because there were so many people.
Obviously.
So they have to limit it a lot.
And uh...
She like grabbed my hand.
And was like...
Grasping my hand.
She was like...
Holding onto me really tightly.
And...
The person who like...
You know...
Kind of...
Me...
Like...
Facilitates the pictures and everything like that.
She was just like...
She was like...
Okay.
It's time.
And so I'm trying to leave.
And she's...
She's pulling me back.
And she's just like...
Come back!
Come back to Japan!
And the...
And the person...
Had to literally like...
Karate chop our hands.
She was like...
It!
Chikan desu!
It was so cute.
Uh...
Um...
And she like...
Karate chopped us.
And I was like...
Uh...
Yeah.
I love my Oshii.
I love my...
Chikan?
No!
Ji!
Jiikan!
But um...
Yeah.
And uh...
Oh my gosh!
Um...
The last day I was in Japan was my birthday.
So October 1st.
And...
I went to go see the billboards in Akihabara.
And then...
I was like...
Well I'm in Akihabara.
And you know what?
You know what they said?
Metal Gear...
John Metal Gear said...
Starting in October...
In arcades all around Japan...
There's gonna be the Metal Gear...
The Metal Gear...
Um...
Stuff in the Crane games.
And I was like...
What?
Yeah!
So...
Basically...
I...
I was like...
Well I'm gonna be in Akihabara anyway.
For the billboards.
And I went early.
And I waited.
For the arcades to open.
I sat outside the arcades.
And I waited.
I waited.
And I was just like...
Okay.
I'm gonna be the first one in there.
I'm gonna be...
Looking around.
I'm gonna be searching everywhere...
For...
Metal Gear games.
For the Crane games.
And guys...
I went to every...
Arcade...
In Akihabara.
And they lied.
Starting in October...
My butt!
I got my hopes up.
I was so excited.
I was just like...
I'm gonna go.
They said starting October.
They didn't need to give a date.
But they said October.
So I was like...
Maybe October 1st.
They said starting October.
They did not give a date.
They lied.
They didn't give a date.
They just said starting October.
That they would be in the Crane games.
And so I was like...
I know it's October 1st.
But maybe.
Maybe.
My little heart pleaded.
I was like...
Please.
It's October.
And then...
Yeah.
I got played like a damn fiddle.
So angry.
Liable for psychological damage.
I'm so angry.
Yeah.
It was a big bummer.
I'm not gonna lie.
I was actually...
Because I was...
I was running to different arcade...
Like...
Arcades in Akiba.
And maybe I should have gone outside of Akiba.
But...
I didn't wanna like...
Go too far.
I had my stuff.
And...
I wanted to...
I had to see the billboards and everything.
So...
Like...
Akiba has so many arcade...
Arcades.
I can't...
I keep saying arcade games.
They have so many arcades.
So I was like...
Maybe I should go to Ikebukuro.
I don't know.
But...
Not even on like the...
Sometimes...
Arcades will have like a little poster that shows like future...
Future items that are coming to crane games.
And they didn't even have it on there.
So I'm like...
I was so angry.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's enough of me yapping, I think.
Okay.
I'm going to have to buy it all in Mercari.
Marked up.
I'm going to buy from the scalpers.
Nooo.
But honestly...
I think they'll probably be...
Or rather...
I feel like they should be reasonably priced.
I feel like they would probably be the amount that I would have paid just trying to get it out of the machines myself.
Because I'm not very good with them.
I'm not very good with them.
Wishing you get the cardboard box plushie.
I need it!
What proxy do you use?
I use Baii.
I just use Baii.
Like I order the stuff myself.
And I have no more Japan trips until the end of the year.
Which is another idle graduation.
That's just my afterlife recently.
So sad.
Happy belated birthday, Minto!
Just watched yesterday's VOD.
Very funny, especially the ads.
Is there going to be a version B for 3.0?
Version B?
What do you mean by that?
Yesterday was so packed with pika I actually forgot to say this.
I hope she dies.
Let's go!
Death day?
Yeah.
I get it.
Please upload your ad so I can loop the Haters song.
Haters!
Spicy.
Oh!
Actually...
Uh...
My mama made my panties kinda spicy.
Hahaha.
Originally...
Originally, my mama was like...
What if I just put... What if I just use band-aids?
But I think... I think it would scare the rigger.
They would be like, Whoa!
Band-aids!
So, um...
You know...
Would you ever consider moving to Japan?
No, not really.
I don't think I'd want to.
Yeah, my mama's kind of awesome.
And you have at least a bandage toggle.
I'm gonna RTA getting banned from YouTube.
We kept joking about that actually.
We were like...
We would suggest something and then we'd be like...
Oh yeah, that would get banned from YouTube for sure.
Then I would suggest something...
We just kept saying things that would get me banned.
Thanks for the membership from yesterday!
Yippee!
Thanks mama.
So true!
Band-aid emote!
No!
But...
Once you see my reference sheet, maybe you'll be like...
Whoa!
They're cute panties though.
It's a little different from now since Maya kinda gave me a leotard, but it's a little different now.
You hear that artist take paper.
Who needs clothes when you have a box?
So true!
I'm not giving you any more hints than what I've told you.
No more hints.
That's it.
Would you jump for the chicken or the beef?
I don't know!
I haven't watched the Civ thing yet!
I haven't watched that yet.
I literally only found out about it like... this morning.
Two things for the Super Chat.
Plays.
At least you're polite about it.
Answer from the heart.
I think I prefer beef over chicken.
So I might actually go for the beef.
How's the TGS vlog?
Oh, I haven't started on it yet.
Actually, I'm really worried about it.
Because I was having issues with my camera.
I should've just bought a new camera, man!
I have an old Osmo... like the original Osmo Pocket.
And, um... I got... I brought... so I brought that.
And, uh...
Every time I would turn it on... well, not every time, but a lot of the times when I would turn it on...
It wouldn't let me film because it would be like, SD card needs formatting.
And I'm like...
What?
I would be like, does... is this...
Is this saving what I'm recording?
So I'm actually quite worried.
Maybe I should've just used my phone.
I don't know!
Thanks for suggesting Jam and Akiba.
First time in Japan last week and it was a chill choice for my not-so-daring friends.
Oh!
I'm glad!
I'm glad you like it.
I love Jam.
It's so awesome.
And the same problem RLM had their most...
Oh my gosh!
I'm obsessed with the most recent Red Letter Media video.
I'm so obsessed.
Of course, my Oshii win.
Ghost hunting.
I love Mike's classes so much.
I love that video.
But then... I saw... actually when I was at the airport...
They had a... what's it called?
They have a big camera... a small big camera in the airport.
And I always kind of like go and look at some of like the stuff.
I'm late.
Did you play the game?
No.
Yeah, I beat the game in 30 minutes.
No, no, no.
I haven't started.
Sorry.
I'm yapping too much because I didn't get to yap yesterday.
I'm sorry.
But I saw this one camera called the PowerShot V10.
I'm gonna look into it if anybody knows anything about it.
But it's kind of what I wanted.
So I might get it and use it for future stuff.
It's kind of expensive.
Well, actually...
I wonder how much it is.
I wonder how much it is in dollar.
Well, that's the thing.
If I turned it off and left it off for a little while...
And then turned it back on, it would be fine.
And then...
If I turned it back on...
If I turned the camera on back too quickly...
It would say it needs formatting.
So...
I got footage on it.
I think.
I would check.
I would be like, it keeps saying it needs formatting.
But you know how you can review the stuff that you filmed.
It was all still on there.
So I'm like...
Maybe, yeah, maybe faulty SD card.
I did switch it out for another SD card.
And it was fine.
After...
I should have done that from the first time it happened.
But you know...
Even in death, you still learn.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, I have an SD card reader on my PC.
All good.
Cool.
Are you ready to play the bathhouse?
Are you guys ready?
I don't know.
I don't really have anything else.
Any other pictures or anything?
Or I have pictures.
But I don't think I really have any other stories.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is a game stream.
Okay.
New game.
Yeah, I don't...
I don't have a game.
It's only continue because...
I started it.
So I could change the settings to not be so high quality.
Okay.
TV table turn.
Thanks for the turning off turn.
Thanks for yappa yappa.
A week ago.
Okay.
Thank you for your hard work today.
Thank you for your hard work.
Today is the cleaning of the sauna.
Oh, no.
I'm cleaning the sauna.
There is a bucket in the cleaning room.
Please collect the towel.
Oh, there's a bucket in the cleaning supplies closet.
Collect the towels and put them in the bucket.
Oh, okay.
How do I get out of here?
Customers who don't follow manners will not be allowed.
Only those who agree and understand will be allowed.
Changing room bathroom facility use manners.
Customers who are drunk or have tattoos cannot enter.
Only children up to six years old may enter any bath.
Wait.
What?
Only...
Oh, oh.
I get it.
Okay.
It means...
When you're six years old...
You can go to...
If you're under six, you can follow your mom...
If you're a boy, you can follow your mom into the women's bath.
But then after six...
Okay.
Wait, I was like, wait.
This is a baby's only bathhouse.
Okay, okay, okay, I get it, I get it.
That makes sense, that makes sense.
Please refrain from wearing swimsuits when bathing.
Do not swim.
No diving.
I don't think it's even possible.
Do not run.
Do not sleep in the sauna.
No photography in the bathhouse.
Please do not bring in any recording devices.
Please do not dye or cut your hair here.
Ew, that would be so gross.
Alright, bathing fee chart.
Adults 12 plus years old.
Above middle schoolers are 500 yen.
Teens are 150.
Kids are free.
Wait, so under 7?
Wait, so, but why do you have to be under 6?
Or up to 6?
Okay.
It's a bit sad.
Oh my god, it's saying...
I'll take that.
Oh, oh, what's this?
Job description.
Maybe that should be behind the counter.
6 is under 7.
Yeah?
But wouldn't it be free and also able to go into any bath in like the same category?
I don't know.
Turn away customers who don't follow the rules.
Greet customers.
Receive payments.
Listen and place necessities in a basket.
Manage water temperature.
Check out customers and the and the monitor and change the water temperature in the boiler room.
Clean bathing room.
Those are my duties.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Again, I really don't remember how this used to look.
I can't.
This is the hardest fabric I've ever...
Oh, God.
It's so stiff.
I can't get out.
Wait, is this the...
Is this the bathroom?
I thought this was the entrance.
No, this is the entrance, right?
Yeah, this is the entrance.
I'm not trying to take a peek.
I'm no pervert.
I mean, not here at least.
Oh, what have we got to drink?
It won't let me crouch.
We got the Ichigo milk.
I'm guessing that's the...
We got fruits.
We got kohe.
We got the gyunyu.
Ice cream.
Did anybody else do that?
Oh, gosh.
I turned it down to high, but hopefully I don't have to turn it down so much more.
Oh, my goodness.
Why is there like an ambience?
Oh, God!
Why is this?
Oh, it's a horror movie advertisement.
What the hell?
Oh.
Oh,
sorry.
The things are kind of delayed.
Okay, here's the closet with our bucket.
Not here.
Okay.
You.
It looks good.
I don't remember it looking this good as before.
Maybe I'm just crazy, though.
I do feel like they're getting better with their games.
They're still kusoge.
But this does look pretty good.
What am I supposed to clean?
He said grab a bucket and do what?
Here?
Oh!
Oh, the towels!
Oh, God!
Oh, my God!
Molly.
I'm scared.
She's gonna be standing out there, isn't she?
Should I leave or...
Yuck.
Oh.
No cutting your hair in the bathtub.
Oh,
my God!
That was the loudest thing ever!
Please!
Holy shit!
Is that my phone?
I'm living on the edge, for real.
Game!
Oh.
Ghost phone.
Moshi moshi!
Audio balance is crazy.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
My goodness.
Hello?
It's been a while.
Yes.
It's been since the graduation from the orphanage.
Is everyone doing well?
I'm gonna put it down to like half sound.
Oh, me?
Yes.
Um...
Huh?
This is such a riveting conversation.
Yes.
Oh, is that so?
Okay.
I see.
What?
I learned so much from that!
You know, sometimes it's good to like just talk out what's going on for the sake of the viewer.
I received a message from the facility.
Who is the facility?
It's from someone who knows me.
They're asking me to come work at their bathhouse.
They also said I can live in an apartment that they own.
It seems like the bathhouse is located in the countryside.
It doesn't fit well in this whole city life.
Maybe I should go.
Hi, ball boy!
Thanks for the gift.
Thank you.
I'm lagging a little bit.
It's raining heavily.
And it's lagging heavily.
I need to hurry and get to the apartment.
It seems my new room will be room 202.
Oh, I can run.
Oh, that makes me feel good.
Vtuber?
How did we get through here?
If we're not allowed through.
Most wanted.
Five?
Five what?
Height 180cm.
Description, slim build, short hair.
Toru Maruhisa.
23 years old.
If you recognize this person, please contact Goku!
Goku really?
Real estate.
Goku is after you, my guy.
You're in trouble.
You are so in trouble.
You'll never make it.
Grandma.
Oh, I don't think that's grandma.
Sorry.
I thought it was a really hunched lady.
Not here.
My place is room 202.
Chief.
Oh my god.
This is Sayuriya.
Movie again.
Is this a real movie?
Is this a short cut?
Here's all the...
The supporter people.
Vtubers and stuff.
Bing bong.
What the hell is that?
Did you guys hear that?
It was like laughing.
A bird?
A plane?
Oh, now I can crouch.
I like seeing all these.
They're always so fun.
Hmm.
I wonder if they're the supporters from the original game or not, you know?
Secret Vtuber.
Hahaha.
Secret.
Okay.
We gotta hurry.
Yeah, I'd assume from the original, right?
Oh my god, a monkey!
A monkey!
Monkey?
Is that what I heard before?
I thought so.
I don't...
Okay.
Oh.
There's a monkey in my apartment.
Okay.
I'm room 202.
But before we do that, we're gonna explore just a tad.
Oh, Vtuber.
Number 16.
Vtuber.
Oh, number 1!
Is it?
Oh my god!
Number 5.
Number 1?
Again?
They're hidden amongst the leaves.
The Vtubers are hidden among us?
Hahaha.
Hello.
Hmm.
Slim build.
Short hair.
Nah, you sure look sussy.
Oh!
Number 6.
Suss.
Oh!
I missed one.
Oh, these are so random.
Randomly placed.
Oh, I found another one!
Number 4!
Quick, call Goku.
I have him on speed dial.
Beep boop bop beep beep.
Goku?
Is my neighbor a freak?
Ping pong!
Huh?
They told me that it would be unlocked.
Uh...
Oh!
I see one right there.
Who's leaving all these little stickers?
I don't have an inventory to call.
I can't ping pong?
Oh, my god!
Hello!
Hello.
You're Maina-san, right?
Welcome.
Thank you for coming.
Oh, the bath house is right across from this apartment.
Very easy to commute, right?
Oh, I see.
This room will be room 202.
It's like eyebrows are twitching.
Your room will be room 202.
It's a bit old, but the interior is pretty nice.
Oh, okay.
It's a bit old, but the interior is nice.
Alright, okay.
Uh...
Maina-san, are you 24 now?
You're 24 years old right now.
Uh...
Yeah...
I'll be turning 24 in three days.
No, I'm still 23.
Gosh, rude!
I'm in my prime!
Oh, really?
Still 23, huh?
I'm glad someone young came to help.
Oh!
Alright, then.
Here's your key.
When you're ready, come to the bathhouse.
Thank you!
Where is he gonna go?
Oh!
I don't think he likes that I'm following him.
Where are you gonna go?
Oh!
Go away!
Yep.
I'm ready for the bathhouse!
Does nobody drive here?
Like...
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oh, it's the supermarket, even.
It's all boarded up, though.
Doesn't...
Oh, whoops.
202.
Doesn't look like it's that late.
It looks like I'm actually holding a key.
Oh!
Nice inside?
Where?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Nice inside?
Oh my god!
It's so dark.
Put my stuff down.
That's all I brought?
Can you imagine the futon?
What is this?
Okay.
Nice.
Weepy!
Am I supposed to hold it?
I'm supposed to hold it.
Oh.
He said the room is clean.
There's a scratch mark.
Where?
Is that money?
Let's go.
Okay.
What?
A scratch mark in here?
Where can I put this?
I don't want to hold it right now.
Unequip.
There we go.
On the floor?
Oh, this?
Hmm.
It looks like it was dragged right here.
Ah, yeah.
I feel really at home.
Look, there's even a TV.
This is actually...
This is the nicest part.
It actually looks like a brand new TV and brand new like little entertainment center.
It's actually...
This is the nice part.
Yeah, what's this placement though?
I'm a vampire?
I'm a vampire.
Yeah.
Sniff the tatami mats.
You do it first.
Hmm.
I can't feel it.
Where else?
I mean, we could put this anywhere else.
Like, move this over.
You could put it right here.
You know?
Like...
Actually, there is no closet.
I thought this was a closet for a second, but this is a slidey door.
This is our closet.
No you.
No you!
But this area kind of terrifies me.
The kitchen is...
The kitchen is actually very spacious.
And then that's probably our toilet.
Which I'm glad that we have even a...
I guess it's good that we have a toilet in our place.
Some places don't have... Some places have like a shared toilet, which is my greatest nightmare.
Oh!
Number four.
Number fourteen.
These... I think I saw number fourteen before.
Yeah, it sounds horrible, right?
Where was the trash again?
Hello?
What if I left it in front of your door?
Oh!
See?
But that's our third number one!
Not everybody can be number one!
This makes no sense!
Give it to the monkey.
Where's the trash?
Oh, here.
Take out trash on day one.
Oh.
I...
Here.
Um...
This stuff always messes me up.
So every... Basically every Tuesday and Friday is the burnable garbage.
Every Thursday is the non-burnable garbage.
For, uh...
Uh, what's a bin?
Like, um...
Uh, like a bottle and cans and, and like the, um...
pet bottles and everything.
Like, like water bottles and stuff.
That's on Wednesdays.
Plastic.
Plastic is two times a month.
So these ones are every week, uh, every, like um, every week.
And these ones are two times a month on Mondays.
And this is the, like, the um, cardboard is uh, three times a month on Saturday.
This is actually how things are.
It's so confusing.
Because sometimes I'm like, I don't even know what's what's a and then also it's just like
Oh!
Plastic is second... Yes!
Sorry.
Yes, you're right.
It's not two times a month.
Second Monday.
Third Monday.
Or third Saturday.
Yeah.
Thank you, Popman!
Thank you, Josh.
Thank you, thank you.
Camera funds.
But it's so confusing because sometimes I'll get something and I'll be like I don't...
I don't know.
Everything is burnable when it's hot enough.
So true.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Okay.
We got work to do.
Your hotels don't have... No, not like a hotel when I lived in an apartment.
Hello, sir.
You're here.
Luckily, a lot of apartment places will... Oh my gosh.
I'm lagging so bad.
But luckily, a lot of apartments will give you like a What's the word?
Like a picture guide.
Why does the game get to look so nice and I get to look so bad?
Yeah.
I'll turn the V -sync on.
Should I turn it off?
From today, you will be working at this bathhouse.
I'll explain what you will be doing.
For now, get behind the reception desk.
Let's see if it helps.
Oh.
Not even a little bit?
Nope.
It's fine.
You don't need to see me.
Here, I'll even like...
shrink myself a little bit.
So that I'm not so annoying in the corner.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Oh, here?
Hello!
Oh, we read all of this?
Hello.
Now follow my instructions.
I'll pretend to be a customer, so just do what I tell you.
Congrats on becoming the first PowerPoint reader.
What if I...
Maybe I should just turn it off.
Maybe I should just turn off my camera.
Oh my god, even notifs are lagging.
This is crazy.
Oh my gosh, I don't think I saw...
I don't think I thanked you earlier, Pyrobug.
Oh, thank you for the 20.
First, make sure you receive the money that the customer places.
Okay, try it.
I'm taking your money.
Next, listen to the customer.
They will tell you what they will need.
Put the items inside this basket, okay?
Okay!
Don't put in items they didn't ask for.
Alright, let's try it.
Wait, what do you need?
Oh, listen.
Body wash, shaver, shampoo, towel.
Oh my goodness.
Towel...
Body wash...
Wait.
Where did it go?
Oh, sorry.
Use towel on the floor?
Body wash...
Shaver...
What did you say?
Body wash...
Shaver...
Shampoo...
Oh, shampoo.
There you go.
Easy, right?
Just do what you just did and greet the customers.
Next, it's a pain in the ass, but...
I will teach you about the work in the boiler room.
Oh, okay.
Why is it suddenly so bright?
Yeah, the towel looks kind of disgusting.
I'd bring...
Oh.
Rude?
You don't hold the door for a lady?
Huh.
What is...
What is that...
What is that symbol?
He's shivering.
It's lukewarm.
Menthol check-in, please.
Thanks, Brian.
I'm currently frozen, so you can basically take...
It's basically like so many times a day.
Oh, okay.
Let's increase the temperature at the boiler room.
Okay?
Yeah, lukewarm.
Ah, lukewarm.
Yeah, yeah.
Here?
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, oh.
This is scary.
This is not where murders occur.
What's over here?
Oh.
Huh?
Oh, I'm in the other area, right?
Wait, huh?
I'm exploring, you guys.
I'm using my detective skills.
Okay, then.
I'll teach you how to change the bath temperature.
If you lower the lever, it will decrease the temperature.
The lower the lever, the higher the temperature.
Why is mint a PowerPoint?
See?
This is why I just want to turn it off.
I'm not going to lie.
I don't want people to keep asking me.
It's because the game is bad.
If you add firewood to the stove, it will increase the temperature.
Don't put anything but wood in the furnace.
Or.
The men's bath temperature is in the orange, so try to keep it there.
The men's bath temperature is low, so we need to increase it now.
You try.
Okay, this is the boy's bath.
Oh, my bad.
I want them to freeze.
I want them to burn.
Burn!
Burn the boys!
You come out as little lobsters.
Burn!
Actually, I wonder if I change the chibiminto if it will be better.
It's okay if I change it.
It's okay if I try.
Let me see.
I'll be right back.
I need to change.
Let's see if I switch the chibiminto if it will be okay.
I guess we'll find out once I go back to the game.
There we go.
Okay.
Maybe it'll be easier.
Why are you guys sending blue?
Kind of.
Oh!
Look at that!
Resync saved me!
Yippee!
Is it good?
It's still not the right temperature.
Should I explain again?
No.
Okay.
So ask me...
I don't know what to do...
Not sure if it works...
try it...
Josh, thank you!
The camera finds me.
Thank you!
You can also check the meter in the monitor that's above the counter.
There's more?
I'll teach you your next job.
What?
There's more?
Okay...
Don't leave me in here, please.
Ochisan, please.
It's too scary in here.
What's my next job?
Oh my god.
Loud.
I'll explain how to clean the place.
I'm gonna start doing karaoke in here.
When the music... when the closing music plays, it's time to clean.
I was told that they're gonna stop using Hotaru no Hikari for the closing song at stores and stuff because too many foreigners are making fun of of...
of, like, Japanese stores for using it.
They're like, Haha!
Happy New Year!
Why though?
For now, I'll show you today's cleaning chore.
Today we're cleaning the bathtubs.
In our men's changing room, bought easily.
Firstly, there's a cleaning supplies closet in the men's changing room.
Catch the valve key and the brush.
Use the valve key to drain the water and then scrub with the brush.
For now, try cleaning the bathtub I can't tell, but that's in front of me.
This way?
Where do I get the valve key?
Here?
I got my brush.
I got a weapon.
Oh, the drain hook.
Okay.
Where's the key?
I got a mop.
PowerShot beat the new camera for us.
No!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Wait, hold on.
Let me ask where the key was.
Yeah.
Wait, explain it one more time.
Valve key.
I don't think I see the valve key.
The hook is the key?
Oh.
Ah!
Broom.
Oh.
Okay,
you don't need to clean the same bathtub again for today.
Can you speak up, landlord?
I'll come by to check before you start
Just do the rest as needed.
I forgot to tell you something important.
This place is haunted!
I'm sure you already know, but there are rules in the bathhouse.
Be sure to send away any customers who don't follow the bathhouse rules.
Kick them out even when they're taking a bath!
Oh my god.
I don't want to kick out naked people.
That means I have to walk into the men's bathroom.
There's no point if you do that after they finish taking a bath.
The rules are pinned on the wall behind the reception desk, so be sure to read it.
I'm lagging again.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Since you seem to have some common sense, I'm sure you'll be fine, my nasan.
Actually, this game is completely breaking my computer.
Because being here makes me feel sick.
It's nothing.
It's because I've got some things to do.
So I'll leave the rest to you.
Classic Chilla's Art game breaking my computer.
One second.
I'm gonna turn off this.
Actually, quit.
Okay.
Maybe that'll help.
Oh!
Ping pong!
Hello!
One moment, please.
I'm... Oh!
Hello!
It's nothing.
Oh!
Take your money.
Wet wipes.
Oh!
Oops.
Sorry.
Where'd they go?
My name's Futa.
Nice to meet you, cutie.
Do you think this place is weird?
It makes you feel restless, right?
Wet wipes, comma.
Where's the money?
Oh, thank you.
Yes, sir.
Towel.
You guys do not use soap?
Oh, my.
Did you start this job recently?
Hey, say something.
I'm not doing my job.
I'm not greeting the customer.
Ugh, so annoying.
I knew girls are no good.
Have a man be at the reception desk instead.
Oh, my God.
He's gay.
It's fine.
He's just not into me.
Are you guys following the rules in here?
There's a monkey in my place.
There's a monkey.
There's a monkey in the bathhouse.
Never mind.
Okay.
Freaky things are already happening, you guys.
Are you following the rules?
I'm coming in.
Oh.
Wow, you are...
I told you he's gay.
Look how close...
Thank
you, always with the rest of the I'm happy.
Now available for pre-order from yeahlights.com.
Thank you for pre-ordering it.
Hey, this guy touched my butt just now.
People like him lower the quality of the bathhouse.
Oh, no.
You should be patrolling and kicking out anyone who's being weird.
Kick the rule breakers out of here.
What kind of bathhouse are you running here?
Ask them to leave.
Come on.
Just a little bit is fine.
He was... he sat like in his lap basically.
Even though he said all that, he wasn't entirely uninterested.
I thought I found myself a good looking man.
He likes some pain.
He likes some choker.
What's his problem?
I'm going home.
I mean, he already paid, so...
And also, where else are you gonna go, huh?
Futa?
Where else are you gonna go?
You need...
Oh, my God.
The stench is following him.
Futa, this is why you need soap!
Dude, it's a slug.
Literally.
Coming!
Oh, I have a line up.
Sorry.
Yes?
Welcome!
Body wash.
Oh, see, you get it.
And she knows not to use our shitty towels.
I thought this was the minotaur milking bathhouse.
Oh!
Do I, like, take the money?
Do I have to click on them to get their money?
Shaver towel.
Okay.
Shaver.
Towel.
Maybe they're sharing the body wash.
Oh, my God.
Grandma.
My, aren't you a young one?
Guys, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Are you the new hire?
We come here often.
Pleased to meet you.
Mio-san, why don't you greet her?
I don't like her!
I'm sorry.
She's not a bad person.
By the way, I remember seeing someone who looks just like you.
Who was it?
Uh...
Was it a celebrity?
Oh, my God!
We're hot!
No, nothing like that.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, that's right.
You look just like the last girl who worked here.
Uh...
Do you know where she is now?
I wonder how she's doing.
I haven't seen her in so long.
That was years ago.
But you really do look like her.
Don't you think so, too, Mio-san?
Hmm?
The last employee?
Does she?
She's that girl who suddenly disappeared, right?
I don't think they look alike.
Anyways, I just can't seem to like this one.
You don't fit here.
My, how could you say that?
Don't pay attention to what she says.
Do your best.
Okay?
Aww, thanks, Grandma.
Okay, leave.
Get out.
Go away.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
Why does it get so bright all of a sudden?
Light mode?
Dark mode.
Don't be weird in the bath!
I'm watching!
Don't be weird in the bath.
I'm watching.
I'm sorry if there's a monkey in there, by the way.
I can't find the monkey.
Apparently there's a monkey around here and I can't find him.
Ah!
The job is not done.
Wow!
Wait.
Towel, body wash.
Body wash.
Whoops.
There you go!
My name is Ray.
Oh.
My name is Ray, by the way.
Where do you live?
That's not something you should ask someone.
That's what I always ask people when I first meet them.
Where do you live?
You don't need to answer that.
I'm a genius.
So I can figure out the answer.
Oh no!
Our bath!
You can't see?
Oh no, hold on.
The temperature is going down.
Ah!
The temperature is going down!
It's an apartment that's close by, right?
Oh, am I correct?
Maybe I'll go visit you sometime.
Ew, Ray!
Go away, please!
Ah!
I'm sorry!
Oh no!
Stop slugging my...
Stop slugging!
I'm going to fix it!
Over here.
Wait, it says it's too hot.
How did it get too hot?
I didn't put anything in here.
Sorry.
Police?
I'm so sorry!
Queens!
I'm sorry!
I did not mean to burn your skin!
One moment, please.
Let's clean up their disgusting mess.
What the hell?
Why do they do this?
Kami's cosplaying?
No, I didn't!
Shampoo, towel, wet wipes.
Wipes.
Shampoo, towel.
Oh, and your money.
Oh, what?
Just because you're young, don't get ahead of yourself.
What?
What do you mean by that?
What did I do?
I'm just trying to live!
Trying to live!
All that ectoplasm.
Do you want our addresses so you can haunt us?
I already have them.
Well, I don't need your address to haunt you, basically.
I think so.
In the countryside, you have to work for the community.
Where did you come from?
Can't answer.
What a rude kid.
Actually, I'm gonna put in more stuff into your...
I'm gonna put more fire.
I'm gonna actually burn you alive.
He said don't put in anything else other than the wood.
But what if it just smelled for like a little bit?
I came from the city and I've been struggling.
You should be more considerate.
By the way.
How can you let that dirty woman in?
It's disgusting to breathe the same air.
Let alone the same bath.
Wait, what are you talking about?
The grandmas?
What do you mean by that?
Disgusting woman.
Who did you see?
I'm scared.
What do you mean by that?
There's an ugly lady in here?
Now there is.
Now there's an ugly lady in here.
Oh my gosh.
I thought that was a baby head for a second.
Are they in the men's bath?
One moment.
I must check for ugly people.
One second.
Any uglies?
No.
I think we're okay.
Hello.
Towel.
Okay.
Do I never give these people their change?
Like, doesn't it say it's only 500 yen?
I take their thousand yen and I just let them go on their merry way.
Hi there.
Hey, hold up.
Do hot guys like that come to an old crusty bar?
Bathhouse?
Like this?
Oh wait, there was a guy in there, wasn't there?
Amazing.
Like, he's like totally my type.
What are you talking about?
Didn't you see?
Come on, you felt the aura at least.
I don't know how much is a good price for a bathhouse to be honest.
I don't go off.
But isn't it illegal for him to be in the woman's side?
So you're telling me that's allowed?
If you're hot?
Oh no.
Too ugly.
I don't know.
Is this okay?
But that's also kinda hot.
Where?
Huh?
In here?
Is there men?
Are these people delusional?
What are they seeing?
I'm so confused.
We were just in here.
No, no, no.
You must leave.
Ask them to leave.
They can't have their bathing suit on.
I wanted to use my favorite floaties.
That's a bummer.
This place is nuts.
I can't...
I'm gonna get fired on my first day.
I'm gonna get fired on my first day because I'm not paying attention.
Wet wipes, towel, shampoo.
And take your money.
You're young.
So you're the new girl in town my boss told me about.
I can see why the owner hired you.
This is an update to an old game?
Yep, yep.
Well, they basically remade the old game.
Because the old game had a game breaking bug in it.
What do you mean by that, ma'am?
This is an update to an old game?
What do you mean by that?
I must follow everybody because you're all such freaks.
No tattoos!
No!
I must ask you to leave.
Huh?
My boss told me tattoos are allowed here.
You're getting real cocky now, aren't you?
You better watch out.
Sorry, she's glaring at me.
It's just the rules.
I know.
She was so pretty.
Oh
Shampoo How old is your kid?
Is the child under 7 years old?
What are you talking about?
It says that kids under 7 years old...
it says that kids under 7 years old...
can go into the woman's bath, doesn't it?
If you're going to work at a bath house...
you better remember the bath rules properly!
That's why I asked!
How old is he?
He's staring at me.
Don't forget about the temperature.
I fixed it!
How old are you, kid?
How old are you?
What if he's eight?
What are you looking at?
You need to wash off before you go in there!
Oh my god.
Back time worker!
Oh no!
Oh no no no!
I'm gonna fix it!
Why is it so dark over here?
Oh my gosh, why does the women's bath keep getting so hot?
I'm not putting anything in here!
Ghost, stop it!
You're making it difficult!
My afterlife is already difficult enough.
Is it warm to your liking?
Oh, it's nothing.
Oh, you're fine.
Sorry.
I'm walking in there with my shoes on.
Any spooky people?
What the hell is that?
Oh, stop!
Why am I seeing like...
You see that trail?
That disappears?
Ghost trail.
Kaya, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Oh!
Oh, it's her.
It's her nasty and disgustingness.
What about the kid?
Likari Madoki!
Where's your kid?
Wait...
No, it's not!
Oh, come on!
What the hell is this thing?
It's a ghost!
What is this?
Oh, we're talking about the ghost!
What are you talking about?
Mr. Kanakazu!
What do you mean, Mr. Kanakusu?
No, it's unintelligible.
That doubtful ghost!
Oh, so you want to be this girl?
Yeah.
Oh, I know, but she's supposed to be...
I have to go and get the kid out of my room, so...
Can you come with me?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
You hold up that rope, then.
Okay.
Noooo!
Aww man.
I'm just literally in the middle of saying, is this where the scary stuff happens now?
The real horror of this game is the rude customers.
Oh god, be careful.
There's a spirit in this bathhouse.
That spirit meant phantom.
Oh hey, your mom left already!
My mom?
I don't have a mom.
Oh, where are you going?
Hey kid!
You need to change!
Kid!
You can't go out!
Gosh,
this is so much for one person.
This is too much for one person.
I guess there's nothing here.
I don't like that I'm like, looking down, you know?
So directly at the...
It makes me feel like anything can pop out, you know?
Aww man!
This is hard work!
This is the...
This is the hard, hard work!
Okay!
Ghost, I just got here, okay?
You be nice to me, please.
Wait, why am I draining it?
To clean it?
To then fill it back up?
To take a bath?
This is...
Is someone there?
I'm sorry!
The bath house is closed for today!
No, that's not true.
I'm an employee here.
Um, we don't have enough buckets here.
Uh, there isn't enough buckets, so...
Can you throw one to me?
What?
Uh...
Huh...
Huh?
Where do I get the bucket from?
This is...
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
But she sounds cute, so...
Oh wait, one of these...
Please don't come here.
One of these?
Oh, sorry.
Uh...
Colby?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Oh, I forgot to get this one.
Oh, hi.
There they are again.
I love...
I love you.
Today's cleaning.
Everything is done!
I'll take a shower.
Where?
What?
Oh, here.
Oh my god!
Face down?
Why do I look so scared?
The egg.
Oh, I'm washing?
I'm washing, I'm washing.
Oh god.
Naked boy!
What do I do?
It won't let me keep washing!
Oh, face down.
There's somebody naked in here!
And a monkey!
This place is so cursed.
Oh my god, why are the lights out?
What happened?
Why did the lights go out?
This place is crazy!
Just run.
It's a damn monkey.
Why are all the lights out?
Monkey!
I'm going home.
The job is done.
No!
The job is done!
Please!
What do you mean I did my job?
I don't get paid enough for monkey.
In here?
Oh my god.
Oh!
What the hell?
Oh my god!
They killed the boy!
What?
What is...
Oh my god!
There's literally Planet of the Apes up in here.
Oh, time for work already.
Oh, I don't want to go!
I don't want to go to work!
Five more minutes.
Just five more minutes.
Okay.
Time for work.
What was that all about yesterday?
Yeah.
That's an understatement, I think.
Yeah, what was that about?
What?
We love Uniqlo, it seems.
Good thing we don't dry our stuff outside.
Oh wow!
We got all of our stuff and everything.
Yesterday was monkey day.
Quit monkeying around.
I'm admiring!
I'm not being Ojiisan!
I'm thinking of how cute they are and how I don't want them to get stolen by a monkey!
Duh!
Um...
Let's get our best Zero.
Oh my god.
Rain again.
Oh!
Hello.
Neighbor.
Is everything okay?
Have you tried the doorbell?
This town is bizarre.
Can you imagine if like...
Kind of like how Fierce to Fathom, they're just like, this is based on a true story.
Can you imagine if these were too?
It's like I was working at the bathhouse.
And then...
Oh no!
Oh!
It got destroyed!
I was working at this bathhouse and on my first day a bunch of monkeys killed a boy!
Oh.
Hello.
I'm sorry I had a rough day yesterday.
Yeah.
I did.
Oh.
Ray.
Yeah.
That guy.
The...
The pale guy.
Right?
I like how in Japanese he says his name.
But...
Here.
They just call him like...
They're just like...
Yeah.
That guy.
That guy who needs sun.
He probably had too much to drink.
It's common amongst young folks who visit here.
I wish it would stop till...
There were a lot of monkeys.
Monkeys?
This is a rural area.
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
The inaka.
Monkeys are everywhere!
What about the dead guy?
They're pretty common around here.
So don't worry about it.
Oh.
Today we're going to clean the walls.
Yeah.
What about the dead kid?
And the hair!
The monkey cult.
Planet.
The planet!
Planet of the apes uprising!
What about any of that?
Spray the walls with detergent and then scrub them with a scrub brush.
Sorry.
Spray cleaner and a scrubber...
Oh.
Spray cleaner and a scrubber are in the toolbox.
I don't think I will.
And when you're done today you can take a bath.
Ah.
I see.
Oh yes.
I almost forgot.
Today is the day of Keiichi, the regular visitor.
Yeah.
I'm still getting over my jet lag.
Today is the day our regular visitor Keiichi comes over.
Long time no see.
Oh.
He's my good friend.
It's been a while since he visited.
I've been looking forward to this day.
I've been looking forward to this day for your friend to come visit you at the bathhouse?
Okay.
He's a stern looking man and wears a suit all the time.
Make sure you send him through.
Okay.
Why are you leaving then if your friend is coming?
Wait.
So I scrub the walls?
What is this?
Oh.
This is the walls I scrub I guess.
I see.
Towel, shaver, shampoo.
Towel.
Shaver.
And a shampoo.
Hey.
Come on.
Imagine if it was based on a true story like Parasocial.
Wait.
Parasocial is based on a true story?
I haven't played that one actually.
You're really slow at your job.
I guess being young doesn't mean you can do the job right.
What?
You have to pick up the pace.
I'm streaming.
I have to entertain my child.
Don't you think I can do your job better than you?
Okay.
Then you work here.
Don't take the job lightly.
Everyone here is so rude.
I'm going to kick this lady out for no reason.
You can leave.
So what do I do?
I get the...
He says I have to scrub the walls.
Okay.
He says I get the stuff and I...
Let's check on the temperature real quick.
Her name is Kaiden.
Yeah.
Clearly.
Let's lower that a little bit.
Okay.
This women's bathroom is good.
I get the stuff from here and I scrub the walls?
Oh yeah.
I guess after everybody is gone.
Okay.
But what is...
What is...
Why is there that here?
Oh God.
Oh my.
A wet wipes shampoo towel.
Wet wipes shampoo towel.
There you go.
Oh Jo-chan...
Oh Jo-chan?
Young lady, you have a nice body.
But Edward, is that Edward Cullen?
If you lose a bit more, but...
More weight!
You'd be more popular!
Can you cook?
No.
You can't cook even though you're a woman?
Women need to be perfect in housekeeping and childcare.
You're still young, so it's a close call, but...
You pass.
I'll let you be my woman.
Minto, my woman.
I'll pass.
You're a shy one.
Monkey's spooking.
I don't hate that.
Well, for today, I'll just get in the bath.
Jukebox, don't do that.
It scares me.
I must clean up.
I must clean up her disgusting nastiness.
Everyone asks for a towel, but no one uses it.
Let me make sure he's not being a freak in there.
He probably... Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh god, talk about a pale, skinny guy.
So...
Slender man over here.
Geez, I need a damn jump scare.
Can you cause him to drop his ass?
So true.
At least he's...
Yeah, you say I need to eat less.
You need to eat...
Why are you going into the boiler room?
What are you doing?
What are you...
Oh god!
What is wrong with him?
Get out of me!
Leave, please!
I'm trying to ask him to leave, but he's...
Sorry, he's really scaring me.
Stop!
Leave!
He's not leaving!
You need to leave.
You guys, he's scaring me.
He's scaring me so much.
Can I ask him to leave?
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
I'm sorry.
Listen.
Shave or shampoo?
Wet wipes or body wash?
Wet wipes?
Body wash?
Was it busy today?
Not that many.
Really?
Well, it's not like there wasn't any customers at all.
I hope a lot of customers come.
There he goes.
What's happening?
He's scaring me.
I'm glad he's gone.
Oh my god.
He scared me so much.
He left his stuff.
Sir!
Why does he need the shampoo?
That's a good question, actually.
What the?
Um.
Let me try this.
Let me just take one last photo- That's two!
Get out of here.
What?
Stay away from me!
I'm leaving!
Wait, what happened?
What's behind me?
What's there?
I saw a ghost in the photo.
Hello.
Towel, body wash, shampoo.
Why is a little girl like you working here?
I'm 19!
Forever!
That guy didn't even hire me when I told him I wanted to work here.
Whatever, a girl like you won't be able to manage the workload in this- You know what, please.
Denko-sama.
Denko-sama, please switch with me.
I will take all the credit, but you can work here.
It's fine.
I'll give you three days until you quit.
Well, do you follow the rules of the bathhouse, or are you a freak?
Well, do you follow the rules?
I wish the ghost would haunt these people.
Seriously!
This ghost has nothing to do with me.
Everything seems normal.
I'll go check the temperature in a second.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
You are doing everything wrong!
You need to leave!
Why do I have to get kicked out by a little girl like you?
What are you saying that I've done?
This job is too much for you.
Now I have to clean this up!
Oh my god...
Lady!
Wait, is it this?
Or is it the scrubber?
Oh, wait, no, it's this- Oh god, that scared me.
I heard- Yeah, yeah, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Robin.
Hello?
Body wash, towel.
Towel...
Body wash.
Hello?
Oh, never mind.
Um...
No, never mind.
What?
What's wrong?
I feel like this place is too small for, like, foreigners.
Maybe a jet program.
Yes?
No.
Um... towel.
I want a towel.
The small Japanese towel.
Understood, I'll bring it.
Okay.
Um...
Yes?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Hello?
He's very polite.
Ah, ah, no.
Oh!
What is that?
What are you- Why are you in this small town?
This is like that one- What's that anime?
Or not anime, that, like, movie about the Yankee girl and the Lolita girl that live in, like- Oh!
Sorry, hold on.
I gotta make sure this is the right place.
This guy's not being weird in here.
Real quick.
Okay.
He's being normal.
Everything's fine.
Um...
Towel, shaver.
Shaver.
Towel.
Money.
No!
Amateur!
The pure, the true, the beautiful!
I'm Amateur!
It's been so long since I last went to a bathhouse.
Amateur!
It gets me excited.
Wow.
Amateur!
I like how that one guy's stuff is still here.
He just zombied out.
She's an eye- Oh!
The temperature!
Oh no!
I'm sorry!
No!
I did bad!
I'm sorry!
It's too hot.
And then we need to put more in here, actually.
So, this is good.
We'll do this before she gets angry.
And...
That should be good.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Ehhh!
Get me out of here!
Run, run, run.
And we gotta clean up this guy's mess.
I'm sorry, sir!
I'm sorry that it was unsatisfactory!
I'm so sorry!
That's Hora e Emma, and that's Hora Emma.
She's an actual Japanese VTuber.
She's a guest appearance for this game.
What?
That's so cool!
Emma-chi!
Oh my god!
How do they make the characters in this game even more horrifying?
Is she being normal?
Yeah.
Sorry, Emma-chi.
I don't mean to come see you in the bath.
I'm just, you know, checking if everything's okay.
Ah!
Hello?
Oh!
Yeah!
Wet wipes!
Chi!
Work faster!
I think we got a spooky...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Bye!
I hope you had a good time here!
I think this lady's about to be a freak.
Oh, let me...
Let me clean.
She's about to be a freak in here.
I know.
It's nothing.
Once...
You're fine.
Where's that guy's friend?
Okay.
So far, normal.
Kind of.
Is everything okay?
Oh, I forgot a spot.
I missed a spot.
I'm coming!
Hello!
Oh!
Hello, short king.
Towel, shampoo, shaver.
Towel.
Shampoo.
Shaver.
Where's your money?
I was excited for the bathhouse.
I don't think you're a kid.
What?
Are you a child?
Are you a...?
Look at the way he's glaring at me.
He's gray hairs.
Hey, hey, hey.
Wasn't that him on the poster?
Oh my god.
What!?
Ah!
Excuse me!
Why can't I?
I'm sure so?
I'm the same?
I'm the same as a kid!
I'm a kid, so anything I do is okay!
Huh?
It's a crime?
Sorry.
He's moonwalking out of here.
Is this lady?
Oh, this lady is leaving now.
One second...
That's the guy!
Call Coke!
Everybody call Coke!
Oh my god!
Oh!
He doesn't want anything!
He didn't even talk!
Are you sure you don't...
Uh oh, I think something really spooky is gonna happen because the ghost is gonna be like...
It's him!
My killer!
Yeah?
Why is he moving in slow motion?
Hello?
What's going on?
What?
He's heading off into anime battle!
You're short?
It's the same as a kid!
Yes?
Can I help you?
He's acting cool.
Yeah?
Why are you coming towards me?
Shut the door!
Oh, he's leaving.
Body wash, towel, wet wipes, shaver...
He didn't even bathe!
He just walked in and looked around!
Body wash...
Towel, wet wipes, shaver...
Money.
Hey, you!
Why are you working at a place like this?
Were there no other options?
I guess not.
Extremely unclear which parts of the horror are on purpose.
I know.
It's just how it turned out for me.
Things turned out for you?
You were probably just a neat or something, weren't you?
Why are you so...
Why is everybody so rude?
You give off a...
I'm very delicate so I can't work kind of vibe.
My skin is paper...
And my bones are glass.
So you got a man?
M-A-N!
A man!
I'm asking if you have a boyfriend.
I don't have one.
Is that so?
You seem like it.
Oh my god!
Well, even if you had a boyfriend...
He'll probably...
He's probably a worthless guy.
You'll need to go back to English school.
Someone like that will suit you perfectly.
You don't even know me!
Why is everyone so mean to me?
Why is everybody so mean to me?
Why do I just accept this abuse?
Can I kick her out because she's wearing that hat?
Can I kick her out because of the hat?
Hit her with the mop.
For real.
Ten gifted if you kick her out.
Lucky.
Wait, where is she going?
Time to kick her out.
Where did she go?
Ma'am?
Lady?
Where the hell did you go?
Wait!
Are you in here?
What?
Where did she go?
Her hat!
Goku?
Goku, you got the wrong person.
Oh, this must be the friend.
Shampoo, body wash, towel, shaver.
Shampoo.
Body wash.
What was it?
Towel?
Towel shaver.
You're a new hire.
My name's Keiichi.
Keiichi.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too, Mr. Keiichi-san.
Let me go check the temperatures for you.
I'm scared though of going in here.
The lady!
She's completely gone!
Oh shoot.
Why did the light do that?
Oh my god!
Is everything fine for you, sir?
What?
Can you wash my back?
Am I gonna get fired if I don't?
Do it?
Okay.
Hey, you say something?
Say that again.
It's nothing.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
Hey, you have tattoos!
Oh...
I can't allow you in here!
Just watching this guy.
You done?
Oh, I guess so.
Let me ask you something.
Why is a young lady like you working at a place like this?
At least he's not stepping on his back.
Can you stop?
I know the bathhouse owner.
Is that so?
That old man, is he a relative or something?
Well, that's fine.
You know, this place is owned by my company.
And it's the only reason why it's still standing.
The owner, well...
He isn't the most reliable guy, but...
He follows orders.
So I let him be.
I even gave him permission for you to be here.
What?
You know that?
What do you mean by that?
But I've changed my mind now that I met you today.
Now why don't you come to our company instead?
A fine lady like...
Oh, sure!
I would treat you very, very well.
Yeah!
Get me out of this place!
No, thank you!
Oh my god!
No!
Me!
What?
Tashi is so stupid!
Tashi baka!
Japanese Magneto?
You have the guts to turn down my invitation, huh?
You got some balls, lady.
The only problem is that you don't.
And I could easily get you to be sitting on my lap with force.
You know that?
What's happening?
Keiichi-san, are you okay?
Keiichi-san?
Yeah!
The power of the ghost...
is gonna kill you!
You okay?
You can leave now.
At least he takes his stuff.
Now get haunted!
Get haunted!
I think I had to have scratched his back.
I think the game probably wouldn't have let me otherwise.
Goodbye!
You're no-
I'm sorry!
You messed up today.
Well, I guess you did okay today.
Good luck tomorrow.
Do better tomorrow.
By the way, did Keiichi come?
Oh, by the way, did Keiichi come?
How was Keiichi-san?
How was he?
Did you notice anything unusual?
He was acting a little strange.
Oh, I see.
Even Keiichi.
I'm glad I called you, Mayuna-san.
I guess by the ghost?
Well then, clean up and go home.
Okay.
Today we clean the walls, right?
Aw, man.
I hope nothing spooky happens.
Is it like this?
See?
What is this that keeps appearing?
That makes no- Oh, it's these!
I'm an idiot.
Oh, what's this?
I keep forgetting I can check it here!
Oh my god, Five Nights at Freddy's, my ass.
What?
No, sir.
I think I'm good.
What do I do here?
Oh, I don't like this one.
Okay.
Where else?
Oh, you see over there?
The Hat Lady.
Yeah...
She'll just, um...
never be seen from again, I guess.
Here or on the other side?
I think it's the other side.
How did those get on the wall?
Uh...
The Hat!
What you do?
This part I can't tell if I'm doing it correctly, but...
Fighting Goku.
That lady?
We didn't know she's Chi-Chi.
I opened this door and I'm scared of it.
Am I going to be able to sleep tonight?
I hope I don't have nightmares.
Oh!
That doesn't look very clean.
Did the desk bell ring?
Did it?
I didn't hear it.
Let me see.
That looks like hair.
That looks like a scary ghost lady.
When I said 10 gifted if you kicked her out, I didn't know that was going to happen.
Well, um...
It didn't, right?
I didn't hear it.
Oh wait, who's...
Oh, that's the Hat Lady.
Her stuff is still here.
There's smoke coming from the boiler room!
Let me go check.
That's a person.
That's just a... Oh my god, is the lady in the boiler?
Wait... Hat Lady!
Ma'am?
Why are you setting my place on...
Oh, she's getting hugged.
Oh!
She's getting dragged away.
What did you burn?
You're messing up my whole... everything.
What is that?
I guess it's fine.
Oh my god!
Uh...
What happened here?
Hat!
Lady!
There was smoke coming out!
Oh!
His eyes.
What happened to him?
I didn't... Sorry, I clicked too fast.
I think he said it happens.
I'll fix it.
Go take a bath in the meantime.
And then go home.
Okay.
I'll go take a bath.
I'm not even gonna think about it.
Bath time for me!
I'm not even... I got my razor and everything.
Face down.
Yes?
I know... Oh god, she's gonna jump at me because I'm ignoring her!
I know...
I'll take my time in the bath today.
Really?
Are we insane?
What is wrong with the bath?
I think there's...
Okay.
I'll take my time in the goo today.
Is this it?
Is this all I do?
I'm having my back against the wall.
Can I leave?
Ah!
Excuse me, is anyone there?
Oh, you're from yesterday.
What happened?
I'm an employee here.
Um, can you throw the duck where you went?
Why are you bathing in the men's area?
There's a rubber duckie by you.
Could you throw it back to me?
Rubber duckie?
Sure.
Where?
Rubber duckie?
Do you guys see a rubber duckie?
Oh, here.
How do I grab it?
Oh, there we go.
Hold on.
I have butterfingers.
Hold on!
Is this supposed to be like this?
Oh, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Call me.
Oh, I think I just threw it into the window.
What?
What just happened?
There we go.
You're welcome!
What?
Stop!
Sorry.
Is there someone over there?
What?
Yes, I'm here.
I'm an employee here.
Could you throw that duckie by a...
Sure.
I can't grab it, lady.
My game, I think, is kind of bugged.
Is the water red or is it just me?
I know.
Oh, I can leave?
Oh, oh, I'm supposed to throw it this way.
Just kidding.
Sorry.
She's not there anymore.
Why do you need the rubber duckie over there?
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I can't grab her duckie.
I think my game is bugged.
Lady, please.
Oh, I keep messing up.
Come on.
Nice.
I know.
My hat's over there.
Could you...
Stop!
I don't like this.
This one's really off-putting.
We've been talking to each other.
Could you throw it back to me?
Okay.
I know.
Oh, it's like really off-putting because I feel like she's moving around everywhere and it's scaring me.
Can I pick up this damn thing?
Why can't I pick up this?
I have the most butterfingers ever.
I can't pick up your damn duckie.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
Yeah, she is kind of scary.
She's kind of getting closer, isn't she?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, okay.
Ew!
It's covered in hair!
Oh, I messed it up.
I don't know where to go.
Oh.
Ew!
Oh, my God.
It's...
It's got a little... a little toupee.
A little toupee.
I can see your hair now.
Don't..
Don't come back, please.
Don't come back, please!
It's got sideburns and everything.
Oh, my God, he's really gross now.
Oh, he's really gross.
Is he getting bigger or just me?
Hello?
Can I leave?
No, I can't get out.
Hello!
Oh, no!
Oh my god.
Ducky.
Please.
Please, rubber ducky.
What was that?
Oh, there it is.
Wow, he's actually properly like...
Oh my god.
Am I supposed to grab him?
Anime guy, thank you for my push-up.
What was that?
What was that noise?
Um, excuse me.
I'm a staff here.
Um, can you throw the duck over there to me?
Um...
Over there?
I wish I could... okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she threw her wig at me!
Thanks, rubber duck.
She threw her wig at me!
Oh, is that her?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Please keep praying.
Please keep praying for my bathhouse.
Okay.
I know.
Five more minutes.
I don't wanna go!
Get
out of here, Kevin!
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Get out of here.
Fishmire.
Thank you.
That was biggest jump scare so far.
I shouldn't have accepted the job.
You can still quit.
Just quit.
Oh.
Someone's knocking at my door.
Sweater?
Blue.
Oh, these ones are so cute!
More Uniqlo.
Knock, knock, knock.
Anybody here?
Oh my god!
Hello, sir?
Why am I letting him inside my house?
Oh, okay.
How are you?
Did you sleep well?
Probably yesterday.
Um, the bathhouse is haunted.
Scary things happened yesterday.
I heard a woman's voice saying she was an employee.
Oh, which one should we pick, you guys?
I don't think we should be so direct about saying it's haunted.
I think he'll be like, nah.
I don't know.
Three?
I was thinking three, yeah.
This thing... these kinds of things happen time to time.
And the... because it's the countryside?
You see spirits and the like appear.
Usually, there aren't many people around.
Oh, in places where there are fewer people around.
So, he knows?
This village is not haunted by spirits.
Wait, then you should definitely have two people working at a time.
That's what happens in a rural place like here, too.
Ah, but... what do you think?
Ah, but yeah.
If it's a curse or a spirit...
W-w-w-what?
N-n-no-no-no-no-no-no!
Wait, I did not mention a curse.
If you're talking about curses and spirits...
Before you head to work, try the nearby shrine.
A priest should be there to help you.
Go talk to him!
I'm sure that priest could do something about it.
I'm worried for you, Myna-san.
And it's important for you to work without stress, you hear me?
So, please go.
What do you mean, we're almost there?
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
We're almost there, but what?
Now, off we go.
Okay.
What the?
Did you leave that?
Is that mine?
Okay.
We're almost there?
To turning 24?
Oh, I was going to say...
We're almost there to Mintos 3.0.
To re-debut stream.
But you know, whatever.
We saw that guy.
We saw him.
Sayuri.
Imagine if there was like a ghost lady up there or something.
Which way was the shrine?
Oh, they cleaned up all the flowers.
Oh, here?
Hello?
Oh.
Who?
Here, the bath house is no higher.
Wait a second.
I think I remember the story a little bit from the original now.
I think I remember.
A little bit.
Because of the priest.
I won't say it though.
Just in case it's a spoiler for this too.
My name is Maina.
Maina-san.
You speak of how nice of you to come to this village.
Ah, you're so smart.
Have we met before?
Do I look like someone you know?
I don't know about that.
Hmm, perhaps?
Is there something troubling you?
You look like you need some help spiritually.
I'm spiritually burdened.
This is what my ghost therapist says.
Because... if I had one.
Um, strange things happen at the bathhouse.
Strange things.
Well, unfortunately, I do know what you mean.
I sense evil wrapped around you.
And it seems to have intensified since your arrival to this village.
Well, for now, I shall bless you with the power of the Yaoyorozu gods.
Did he just take my money?
Oh, never mind.
Keep this amulet with you at all times.
May the Yaoyorozu light your way.
Oh, thank you!
We have this bracelet and the charm.
My omamori.
Thank you.
I'll keep it with me.
Bye bye.
Any monkeys about?
Hidden Vtuber.
Oh my god.
I'm getting stuck on the walls for Vtubers.
Okay, to work, I guess.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought he was going to keep talking.
Are you okay?
Are you an employee here?
I was called to repair the stove.
And I just finished.
This place... something is...
What?
I don't ever want to come back.
That stove is fine, so never call me here again.
Oh.
Okay.
Can I also leave?
Or...
The job is not done.
He's doing the Shokolov...
The Shokolov shuffle?
Oh, that was fast.
Oh.
Grandpa.
Grandma?
Shampoo.
Wet wipes.
Body wash.
Why do you need the shampoo?
Wet wipes.
Body wash.
Can I come in?
Will you listen?
I promised to meet a friend here today.
But that person developed dementia.
Which is why I'm worried.
Oh!
Okay.
What do you want me to do about it though?
.
Okay.
Let's switch to 4.
Oh, we're on 4.
Let's go to 1.
Are you gonna be normal?
Okay, I think she's normal.
Hello!
I'm here.
Shampoo, body wash.
Yeah.
I don't think you want our crappy shampoo.
I think you need...
You use the nice stuff.
I think she's the one with dementia.
No!
Bathhouse are good for my beauty.
Okay.
Don't use our crappy shampoo though.
I think it'll ruin your hair.
What the?
Oh, that was weird.
Oh my god!
Sir!
Why me?
I didn't do anything.
This is discrimination against women.
What?
I'm gonna get banned off of YouTube if I see your tits then.
No!
You can't have your boobs out on my channel.
That's why I made you leave.
Body wash shaver.
Oh, what about your friend?
Maybe I should wait for them.
Okay.
What?
What do you mean what?
Don't stare at me.
I'm just... What?
I didn't do anything.
Everybody is so mean to me.
When people are like, Mint, why don't you just move to Japan?
Because this is what will happen.
This is what will happen.
What's going on in here, right?
Oh my god.
I learned that you don't have to buy separate shampoo, body wash, conditioner.
You can just buy it from...
No!
What do you mean?
I didn't teach you that!
Is that her?
Who is...
Oh my god, that scared me.
Oh shit, okay, she's going in there.
Oh my god!
We got double, double spooky lady!
Double spooky lady!
Oh, let's also check...
Oh my gosh, the men's...
Okay, the ladies is fine.
One second!
Hold on, I have to go take care of you.
I have to go take care of your water first.
Oh, wrong door.
Oh my gosh.
It's so dark.
Hold on.
One second, it's too cold for you to go into the...
Enjoy the bath.
It's too cold for you to enjoy the bath.
I must set it on fire.
Okay.
That should be good, right?
Yeah, that should be good.
Okay.
Where's the door?
Why can't we get better lights in here?
Okay, okay.
More, more, more.
Fire, fire, fire!
Okay.
Hi, sorry.
Towel.
He doesn't look very happy with me, you guys.
He doesn't look very happy with me.
Chirapin.
Chirachirachirapin.
Chirachirapipi.
Chirapin.
Chirachirachira.
Chiratekesu.
Uh...
Men's get a taste of her own medicine when she is the one who's hated for...
What are you talking about?
Chirapin?
Ah, sorry.
You are not a Chirapin.
Chirakesu follower yet.
Chiratekesu.
Chiratekesu?
Chirapin!
You aren't familiar with Chiratekesu?
Is that like a mascot or something?
That is a troublesome matter.
Chiratekesu is always right next to each one of us.
Its existence is like a god.
No, it is more than a god.
Peace in this world is maintained by Chiratekesu.
And us becoming one.
In other words, it is our peace and our own tranquility.
It is through Chiratekesu that we are released from all pain and sadness.
Can you just go take a bath, please?
And that allows us to reach a new realm.
I see.
Chipinke.
Chipinke!
Do you understand now?
The important thing that is needed is to become one with Chiratekesu.
Is O.
Yes.
This witch contains the soul of Chiratekesu.
It is kind of cute though.
It is normally forbidden for non-believers to have it.
But today I will give you a special offer.
You can have it for one million yen!
I don't have that kind of money.
Chirapin.
Chiratekesu.
How unfortunate.
Even if you cry and beg later, Chiratekesu will not accept and welcome you.
You will trudge on the same path as one before.
You shall regret this.
Chirapin.
I am a Vtuber and you will regret this.
Just go take a bath, man.
Is this lady still in here?
Are you okay?
Oh my god!
It can't be helped, can it?
You can't sleep in here when I go into a sauna.
It makes me sleepy.
Get out of here!
You can't be sleepy.
Why are you sleeping in here?
Ma'am!
You're gonna die.
Chirapin.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Hold on.
Let me double check to make sure this weirdo's not doing anything.
Oh.
Are you alo- Chirapin.
Chirapin.
The Chiratekesu is broken.
He is very angry.
It's because of your sins.
You must have offended him.
You are finished.
Done.
Chirapin.
You must suffer the wrath of the Chiratekesu.
An unimaginable death is now on your way.
Oh.
Okay.
Good.
He's leaving.
Oh.
Okay.
We're done-zo, you guys.
Wet wipes.
Body wash.
Shampoo.
Wet wipes.
Body wash.
Shampoo.
He's making a lot of noise over there.
Why are we getting all these freaks for?
I'm an expert in palm reading for newt telling.
Your hand, please.
Let me read your palm.
No!
Go take a bath!
Actually, what?
Sure.
Hands so beautiful and smooth.
It's been a long time since I've held a woman's hands.
Okay.
Let me see.
Oh.
You seem to have a deep connection with this village.
I do?
Oh my god.
Are you a local by any chance?
No.
I've only recently arrived.
That's not possible.
And, uh, this line here.
You've had some very bad experiences here.
Oh.
Let's see.
Have been in physical pain at this bathhouse in the past?
Not that I remember.
I don't know.
You don't have to lie to me.
And this line here.
You have strong feelings for me.
You have strong feelings of resentment and love towards someone close to you like you're...
Let go of me!
My apologies.
Oh, okay.
I don't have to clean up after her.
Because she was a freak.
Oh, everyone here is weird.
This is the freakiest village ever.
Not only do we have ghosts, but we just have to deal with...
Oh.
All sorts of weirdos.
You're not gonna...
Oh.
We have to shower first.
Good.
Okay.
He's being normal for now.
He's normal for now.
Oh.
He's back.
Oh!
It won't let me talk to him.
The way he looks at me when he is like, stop.
Take care of your own stuff.
Oh!
He's like, stop looking at me!
Oh my god.
Okay.
The cameras are fine.
I think this guy is gonna get killed, maybe.
Are you gonna slow walk again?
Oh my god.
He's doing it.
He's JoJo walking.
He's...
He's powering up, you guys.
Oh no!
Go.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Oh.
Why are you walking like this?
I have to wipe up after this guy.
Okay.
It was fine, I guess.
Only a little bit of a freak.
On the freak meter, like a six.
I think I got all of it.
Oh!
My god.
Oh my god.
My name is Toru.
I'm searching for my twin sister.
Do you know anything?
Can you look at me?
Why is he...
Why is he acting like such an anime protag right now?
Can you tell me about her?
The thing is, I'm not sure.
What do you mean by that?
It's your twin sister.
I know that she's in this village.
Are you perhaps on the poster?
Maybe I was...
I feel like I've seen you before.
Maybe it's that poster with the name tag.
Oh, I didn't say...
You...
I didn't say...
You brought it up.
Was it the wanted poster?
I didn't do anything.
Believe me.
Please believe me.
It seems like there are people in this village who don't really think about me.
There's someone in this village who doesn't think highly of me.
Someone put up that strange poster.
Anyway...
That's why I didn't do anything bad.
It must be a misunderstanding.
If you know anything about my sister, please let me know.
Slow walks out of here.
You know, if you walked faster, you'd look less suspicious, I'm just saying.
The walking is not doing you any favors.
Okay.
Oh!
Hello friend!
Is this the friend?
Towel!
Okay.
This must be the friend, maybe.
There you are!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello everybody!
We're playing Chilla's Art Game.
It's an old game, but it was...
Apparently the old game had a bug, like a game-breaking bug.
So they took it off of Steam and then just remade the whole game.
And now it's a new game.
Hello!
Buffy!
Thanks for the tech gift card!
I've been looking for you.
You really haven't changed.
Let me...
I didn't even see any... Hello?
Apparently thanks for the markup, dude!
That was kind of freaky.
The girl, like, popping up at places is a really good touch, I think.
What's up, grandma?
There's no milk.
Yes, there is.
It's right... Oh.
Wait, you're right.
Uh...
Oh, sorry.
One moment, please.
I must fetch a guio for grandma.
Wait, where's all the milk?
Who's drinking all the milk?
Alvin!
Thanks for the vibe gift card.
Guio?
Guio.
Where do I... There's no milk.
Where do I get more milk at?
Um...
Hold on!
Raffle team, thanks for the vibe gift card!
Hello, sir.
Shampoo.
Okay.
What is a kid like you doing here?
Working?
Can a young lady who seems like she's never been out in society really do this?
Everyone is so judgmental to me!
I'll be struggling even more!
I'm gonna start saying that to people.
Oh my gosh!
I hope you had fun.
Chase, thank you so much for the gift card.
Instead of like saying goodbye to people, I'm gonna be like, I hope you struggle even more.
What the hell?
Where do I get more milk at?
Oh...
I didn't even have time to be scared.
She appeared and then disappeared out of nowhere.
Oh my god, not the squatty toilets.
Fine, thanks for the 10 gifted!
I hate those toilets.
Ma'am, I'm looking for the gyuunyo but I don't know where he is.
I don't know, I already got some.
Gyuunyo?
In the back?
You think so?
Please say no.
Please say, psych.
Okay.
Oh my god!
You are not human!
One moment, please.
I have to make sure he's not being weirdo.
Okay, he's dead, I think?
Well...
I just felt like dying.
Dying is the only way.
Sir, you need to leave.
Wait, he's got that freaky face on!
Get out of here.
Are you gonna make a mess in here?
Do I have to clean up after you?
No, okay.
I don't have to clean up after the possessed people.
Well done!
I hope you struggle even more.
Okay.
Oh, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared!
I don't like being in here at all.
Gyuunyo?
Gyuunyo.
Milk, milk, milk.
There's not even a fridge in here, so...
I feel like there's no gyuunyo.
Relatable.
Okay, I checked.
I was brave.
Alien!
Welcome to Manbusha Park!
Shaver, shampoo, wet wipes, towel.
Shaver?
Shampoo?
The ghost is T-posing at me!
Wet wipes.
What else?
Shaver, shampoo, wet towel.
Sadness.
Sorrow.
Rage.
Only one of these is a Metal Gear character.
Can you guess which one?
Despair.
Oh, in the depth of... bathhouse.
Is she already possessed?
Oh, my goodness, lady.
I think she's already possessed.
Oh, god, sorry, I forgot about you.
I don't know where your gyuunyo is!
Are you gonna be a freak in there?
What are you smuggling in here?
That's not a baby!
Is it?
Oh.
It's nothing.
Sorry.
Be on your freaky way, ma'am.
I don't think that's a...
What are you smuggling in here?
You must find your emotions to take with you into the bathhouse.
T-posing is totally normal.
So true.
Yeah, do you have the milk?
Did you take all the milk?
This area is looking mighty bad.
Is that the freaky face or does she always look like that?
Uh-oh, I think she became possessed again.
I think she's possessed, but like...
We'll just let her be for a minute.
Oh.
I turned away for two seconds!
Do I have to clean that up?
Ew, she's looking at me.
Ma'am, you need to leave!
There's no giving birth in the bathhouse!
I have to write a new rule, you guys.
It's all his fault.
Why the hell did he do this?
That was close.
I was almost pulled by her.
I have to clean this up!
This is a biohazard!
I... Oh my gosh!
She's just leaving!
Ma'am, go to the hospital!
Your baby looks like bacon!
Please!
Go to the hospital!
Oh my God.
Okay.
If you're happy...
Gyunyo...
This lady is still on about the Gyunyo.
I
didn't finish this lady!
There's an NPC that's supposed to sell you milk.
Don't know how to get her to appear though.
Oh my gosh!
Janitor of the month.
Mop the floor perfectly every day.
Good work.
I did a great job!
Can you clean the mirrors today?
Wash the dirty mirrors with the shower then...
Wipe them clean with the cleaning cloth.
Please work hard until the end of today as well.
Can you stay here?
Wait, what about this lady though?
Oh, she's gone.
Okay.
Do I get the cleaning cloth from here?
What is this anyway?
Just a table?
Okay.
Sorry, I thought I heard something.
After a lady gives birth in your place of business, that seems like an appropriate time to just shut down and go home.
This cleaning cloth looks nasty even.
It's getting lonely.
Oh, oh.
Is something going to show up in the mirror?
Hello?
Oh my goodness.
It's so specific.
Every little tiny corner!
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared!
No, I didn't clean up after- That's above my pay grade, okay.
Actually, part of the reason I couldn't work at a... I worked at a fast food place, right?
But because I couldn't clean the stuff well enough...
I was like, nothing... as much as I clean, nothing just...
Nothing becomes clean!
I felt like I had to quit.
I was like, this is...
I mean, there was obviously other reasons, but...
I was like, I just can't clean it well enough.
Oh!
It's still there!
Pink, welcome to Banbosha!
Thank you!
Because you have to clean everything so fast, it's like... not...
It doesn't feel...
What the?
What's going on in there?
This place...
Do I need to mop that up first?
Happy birthday, Mito!
My birthday is also on the 1st.
I'm happy to split cakes with what I'm washing.
Patman, thank you!
Oh my gosh, wait, that reminds me.
I got cake.
I don't think I can clean that up.
I don't have a broom.
Will the mop work, I wonder?
I can't... let me... maybe if I put it away?
Okay.
Let's see if I can use the mop.
Oh.
Nope.
It won't let me clean it up.
Okay.
I'm finally done.
I'll take a shower.
Is that a good idea?
Do I use my hands?
Let's try it.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Wait, why is... uh oh.
There's still a progress bar.
I think I bugged it.
You guys, I bugged it a little bit.
My bad.
Oh no, it's just staying there.
What?
What was that?
I'm scared.
I don't want to look.
I don't really want to take a bath because of yesterday.
Maybe I'll go into the sauna instead.
No!
I'm so stupid.
Let me just sit in the really dark room.
That's scary.
I think I'll try to stay as long as possible.
What do you mean?
What is that?
What?
Wait, I'm confused.
Huh?
I'm at my limit.
I need to get into the bath.
Oh, what?
What?
I'm confused.
Okay.
I'm so stupid.
Why?
I just said that I didn't want to be in the bath.
Okay, one more time.
What?
Oh, okay.
This is strange.
Am I just clicking it?
Oh.
Okay.
I don't like this.
What is it making me do?
Oh, get back in the bath again?
Okay.
What?
It's really quiet.
So it's making me like freaked out.
Okay.
One more time.
Again?
QTEs are why I don't go to the sauna.
So true.
Okay.
I knew this is going to happen.
I can't see, ma'am.
I can't see the QTEs.
Oh.
That's me.
Grandma.
What the hell?
What is happening?
Who's behind you?
Milk.
Do you have milk?
My milk.
What is that behind you?
It's like clipping through the... Oh, it's the fan.
Just kidding.
QTEs.
Okay.
There's milk at my supermarket.
Hey, you.
Come pick the milk up.
Okay.
Oh.
We're at the supermarket.
You have nothing here except fans.
A shooting range?
This looks fun.
Start the game.
Aim down sight.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, don't shoot the people.
Who am I shooting?
Oh, you have a knife.
Maybe don't shoot the little kid.
Or do they have a knife?
It kind of looked like they had a knife.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I keep holding it down.
Oops.
My bad.
Oh, don't shoot the kid unless they have a knife?
It kind of looks like a knife.
What am I supposed to kill?
Oh my God.
Oh, they definitely have knives.
I'm
supposed to kill everything.
Oh my God.
They're going up.
Am I supposed to kill you?
Who has a knife?
What's happening?
Oh, sorry, kid.
Get out of the way.
Shit.
That's it.
If it exists, mint shoots.
Kill everything but the chinchilla.
I killed ten chinchillas.
What's game B?
Show patrons.
Game is playing.
What?
Oh.
Wait.
This is so cute.
Oh my God.
Can I shoot them?
Oh, this is fun.
Wow.
It's so bright in here.
Okay.
Now we have to see if we can shoot the patrons.
Why is she so small?
Okay.
Let's see.
So I shoot everything...
Oh, sorry, chinchilla.
Everything but the chinchillas.
Oh, this is where we...
Money, baby.
I want to shoot the patrons.
Oh, I admit I got two.
Oh.
This is so cute.
I got two.
Wait.
Is this the patrons?
Where is she?
Wait, was that...
Sorry.
Say goodbye, Doki bird.
Good game.
You can shoot Doki.
I don't need to do anything else.
Good game.
Ah, Fuji's side!
I'm sorry!
Oh,
shoot.
That was close.
Sorry, old man.
Oh, damn.
I missed it.
Because these are like different shapes than before, you know?
I can't even tell who some of these people are.
They're so bright.
Not that I would know, but I can't see what they look like.
Oh my god.
Sorry, random girl.
It's kind of morbid to shoot the real people.
Nice.
Well, that was fun.
That was a good little minigame to do.
Oh my god.
Oh, hello.
There's a cat!
Hmm.
Your face.
Eyes.
It's those eyes.
Your eyes.
Where have I...
Ah!
Milk!
If you help with the store, I'll give it to you.
This.
The products in this cardboard box.
Line them up on the shelves.
That was some fancy shooting.
You're pretty good.
Thanks!
Where do I... oh.
R?
Wait.
How do I rotate it?
R plus... oh, okay.
Here we go.
Like so?
Oh, my depth perception.
I just dropped everything on the ground.
Mmm, potato chips.
Oh, whoops.
Okay, this one's a little tricky.
Yes!
Okay.
Can I pet the cat?
You can't pet the cat!
Chilla's art, please!
What kind of game is this?
You can't pet the cat.
Oh, come on!
I had that!
Messed up.
There we go.
Look carefully at how the products on the shelves are displayed.
I did it though.
Oh, on the back too?
No?
What did I do wrong?
Oh, there's one more!
Oh, my bad.
I didn't see it.
I don't... short people don't look up, okay guys?
Also gamers.
Gamers don't look up.
There we go.
Next is this.
All the delicious breakfasts.
Okay.
Uh...
Next gamer.
Actually, I really don't like looking up because, you know, it hurts my neck.
And so, I have... I have to be short.
So, tall people should just have to look down at me and like cater to me.
Why do I give them the satisfaction of looking up?
You know?
That's how I feel about that.
There we go.
Uh...
Face down.
Like so.
Yes.
And then sideways.
Why are you... why are you like this, old lady?
Sideways.
Top one is wrong?
It is?
Hold on, I'll check it in a second.
There we go.
Oh, you're right.
Thank you.
There we go.
Next.
Minto likes being looked down on.
Conversion.
How to talk to short people comic but with mint.
Poki.
I mean...
Distinguishly distinct...
Huh?
Wait, what?
What?
So, laying down?
Like that?
Then upside down.
Yeah, legally distinct sticks.
Upside down.
Then lying flat upside down?
Sorry to get hungry, you guys.
How much... for anyone who's seen this game, how much longer do I have?
I'm halfway?
No way.
Oh wait, this is also upside down, but straight.
Is that correct?
Wait, does this mean it's the only one right?
Huh?
Yellow if correct.
Maybe this needs to be facing the other direction.
No?
What?
But that's literally how it is.
Oh, it's the color too.
Oh, it's got to be blue.
I see, I see, I see.
Because they are color coded.
Okay, okay.
Come here.
Oh, I actually didn't see what color.
But this is the only one we haven't used.
So...
It's down like so.
If I'm elected president, I will make sure all citizens are the same perfect height.
There's nothing wrong with my height!
I might have to get a snack then.
Do you guys mind if I grab a snack real quick?
Actually, I might grab the cake.
I don't think I... I don't have any leftovers.
Let's grab a... let's do a snack run real quick.
Next is the last.
Give me one second.
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
Well, oh, not pizza time.
Hold on.
I'm not even going to the bathroom.
Well, I might go to the bathroom.
I don't know.
I'm going to grab a snack.
And I suggest you guys maybe do the same.
Snack time, baby!
Oh my god.
I had some fruit in my fridge.
But...
I didn't finish before I left Japan.
So it's like not good now.
Which makes me sad.
I forgot about it before I left.
But I went to get some stuff out of my fridge.
The cake.
And I heard something.
Something like...
And I was like, what is that?
And I think the fruit was about to explode.
I
think it was about to explode.
I think, yeah, like the pressure was building up in there.
That's kind of crazy.
Okay.
Cake for my birthday.
Since I didn't have any yesterday.
Oh, I also got some cheese-o-kaki.
Sorry if you heard me crunching on it.
I got some cheese-o-kaki.
It's so good.
It's basically like a senbei with cheese in the middle.
Cheese-o-kaki, my beloved.
Yeah,
I grabbed some snacks before I left.
I usually just go to a convenience store and grab like a party's worth of snacks.
And then have them for like a month.
Okay.
Delicious.
Let's resume our game.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
There was no sound.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Okay, so this is a Gumi.
How am I supposed to...
Okay, I think it goes with the Doritos.
Yeah, I knew it.
Now let's take... No, no, no.
Let's take the ra...
Oh, my bad.
Okay, let's take the ramen.
And we'll put it...
With the cylinders.
Upside down.
Just kidding.
That was incorrect.
Is there like actual drink in here?
No, we have some mag...
Oh, my God.
Wacky inflatable flailing tumen.
Oh, my gosh.
Cat magazine.
This must be stood on its spine.
What a horrible way to...
To present your books.
Wait, this way, maybe?
Did I put it the wrong way?
Oh, my gosh.
I can't rotate it well.
No, please.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
Like that.
No.
This way.
Please, this way.
No.
This way.
There we go.
Yes, okay.
Alright, we got two.
Cookie.
I think that's right.
We just have to get it the right way.
So, this is...
Upside down?
Or like facing down, I think.
No.
Oh, my God.
Now.
No.
Okay.
Alright, now you.
Oh, it has to be facing sideways.
That's what's wrong.
Hey!
We did it.
Oh, let me take off my gone fishing.
There we go.
Kick.
Are you done?
Milk, right?
And this too.
I feel like you should hold on to this.
Here.
Kick.
I can't.
I wish I could get rid of this damn loading bar.
Maybe in the next loading section.
It's been so long.
Maybe over 20 years...
ago.
You look exactly like the employee at the time.
The curse of the bath house.
It doesn't seem to work on you indeed.
This seems to be a reason...
Kick.
The curse of the bath house.
You're being targeted, aren't you, by a very strong entity that is much more than a curse, Much nastier than a vengeful spirit.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Looks like they can't touch you... yet.
I've been here long enough to know a thing or two.
Wait...
The landlord!
And the priest!
They're in cahoots!
Be careful.
Can I pet the cat now?
He did purr!
I think it counts.
Thank you.
Can I take those or...
Ew.
Oh!
That's... icky.
There's dolls everywhere!
That is a pet cat.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
There's dolls everywhere!
Ooh, my eyes.
Alright, bye!
Do I take this to the bathhouse?
Wow!
The market's actually open.
That's kind of fun.
I want to be that cat when I grow up.
But I don't think I can grow up.
I'm a ghost.
It's kind of sad.
Can I have that?
I don't think I can grow up.
Hey, you!
Hey!
That's my daughter's bracelet.
Give it back!
My daughter's precious bracelet!
Where is Ryoko?
Ryoko?
Oh!
Woah, woah, woah.
What are you doing?
Oh!
I don't like this.
Ryoko!
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, I don't like this.
Yoko... Yoko doko!
Here, I'll help.
Yoko!
Yoko doko!
Ah!
Oh!
Woah!
Oh my god!
What the guy?
Oh my god.
Hey,
you finished?
Oh my god!
Did you get hurt?
Sorry.
I was so insane.
Oh my god!
Are you okay?
Landlord!
I was surprised.
I thought you were dead.
You surprised me.
It'll be troublesome if you died?
How about just a bad thing if I died, huh?
Really.
It's not the right time.
I'm not joking.
You can't... Wait.
It's not the right time?
What do you mean?
It's my birthday, Blueslight!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Blueslight.
Also, there was someone else that said it was their birthday on my birthday.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot to wish you a happy birthday.
Happy birthday!
I'm so sorry.
What?
Oh, yeah.
No.
Ah, no.
It'll be troublesome if you don't have a part-time job.
I just meant that it would be troublesome if I lost an employee.
This bathhouse is dangerous.
It's cursed!
Uh, before it collapsed, I saw what happened.
Or, you saw what happened, right?
That was in our brains, right?
I'm just gonna say this bath... Well, I'm gonna say what happened.
Hm?
No.
When I came here, I didn't see anything.
I can't...
I'm sorry.
Something bad happened, didn't it?
You must have had a bad day.
Customer service can be quite tough.
Yeah, especially when I'm abused verbally all day.
No, you don't because you're old and everybody here hates young people!
Why can't I be a hug?
Ahhhhhhhhhh!
My design, I understand what you're going through.
Please, do a little more.
But, please, keep working a little longer.
Oh, it's loading.
Is it gonna get rid of it?
Yay, the loading bar is gone.
I just started this job, but...
I've already packed up my stuff.
I have no clothes.
I don't think I can continue anymore.
I want to quit.
Yeah girl, you quit!
Is it the landlord again?
I really don't want to talk to him anymore.
Ping pong!
It's the priest!
What is that?
What?
What are those?
There's so many of them.
What is it?
Is it bug spray?
Cause...
No, I don't think it's booze!
It has like the long tip.
This is not booze.
I think it's a bug spray.
I think we have like a bad bug problem because there's a dead person.
There's a corpse in our house.
Somewhere.
There's so much!
Uh oh, my chat just broke I think.
Give me a second guys.
My chat just broke.
One second, one second!
Did YouTube break?
What's happening?
Woah, what's going on?
Nothing's loading.
What's...
YouTube!
Yeah, I'm glad it works on your end but like...
YouTube is just showing me...
Here, I can even show you.
It's just loading like this.
For me.
Like I have to go back to the home page.
And...
Hold on.
This is what it looks like.
What the heck?
Nothing's loading.
Oh!
I think I got it.
It finally loaded.
Just a little bit.
Yippee!
Maybe...
Kind of?
Kind of loaded.
Why YouTube?
Why?
It won't let me go to the YouTube studio.
Oh my gosh.
If I press...
Refresh...
What?
It's not even...
Is it... Is it... Is it Firefox?
Might be Firefox.
Sorry guys.
I just will read chat from...
Uh...
From OBS.
Give me a second.
I'll read chat from OBS.
Sorry.
Oh!
Oh gosh!
Hello?
Ah, great.
I have something to tell you.
Something very important about you.
I'm a reincarnated Japanese princess.
There's a basement?
Please go to the basement of the bathhouse.
Oh.
You're in the boiler room.
Go through there.
What?
But please do not be seen by the landlord on your way there.
Sneaking mission?
What if I'm caught?
What's that?
Is that the landlord?
Surely not.
Landlord?
You don't see me, do you?
Hmm...
I'm sneaking?
Kind of.
Actually, I'm just walking...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Hey, did you find something out about my sister?
Did you find something out about my sister?
No!
Is that so?
Perhaps.
Hey, what is your name?
Wait, what's the third option?
I can't pick it.
Happy birthday.
Thank you, Keiko!
It's Maina.
Maybe I missed something, yeah.
That's a good name.
Okay.
See you.
Oh, we can go in here again and stuff.
Oh, look!
We can just... Oh!
Hi!
We can just...
Oh!
Hi!
You just taking pictures in here?
What are you doing in here?
Okay.
See you.
Everybody here is a cosplayer.
See you later, then.
That's funny.
Thank you for the super time!
What did I miss that I couldn't unlock that third option, I wonder?
Hello?
What are you selling?
Hey!
Emojiro!
Answer my quiz.
First question.
What human organ resembles a sweet potato?
Oh my gosh, he is a sweet emo!
Um...
The liver.
That's right.
Nice.
A sweet potato looks like a liver.
It's like eating a liver.
I don't know about that.
Moving on to question two.
Which one can you eat without dying?
Pufferfish, a sweet potato sprout, a cherry seed, every option leads to death.
Is it a sweet potato sprout?
I know potato can be kind of poisonous, though.
Pufferfish is poisonous.
All options lead to death?
Why can't you eat cherry seed?
Does it have arsenic in it?
Or something?
Ah!
You guys were wrong!
You're shit.
Be ashamed of yourself.
He's talking to you!
Answer my quiz.
Okay.
I can do it again.
Liver.
Which one can you eat without dying?
I'm gonna try the sweet potato.
See!
You guys kept saying four, but it's two!
You can eat a sweet potato sprout without dying, everyone.
Today you learned.
Also, I'm pretty sure you're thinking of raw potato.
Unfortunately, it appears you can't kill people by feeding them sweet potato sprouts.
Third question.
What?
Thank you!
Did someone gift a bunch?
Sorry!
I can't see because I have the...
My chat... I'm only reading chat through OBS.
I'm so sorry.
But thank you!
Whoever gifted, thank you!
Third question.
Which food grows a sprout?
Dog, human, rat, sweet potato.
I think it's a sweet potato.
You're doing well.
I'm impressed.
Sweet potatoes do indeed have sprouts.
Fourth question.
Joy Tom Tom.
Thank you, Joy!
Thank you!
Fourth question.
One day a young girl came to the village.
That girl was very pretty and quickly became popular.
A certain man noticed the girl.
He decided to have her work at his business.
But then the girl got stolen from him by another guy.
So what did the man do to the girl?
Punched her, locked her up, burned her body, chopped her into tiny pieces.
I'm not seeing sweet potato.
I'm thinking burned her body because he said if you put anything else other than wood in there, it smells.
I wonder, which do you prefer?
Last question.
Fifth question.
What is going to happen to you?
Oh!
Get locked up forever, get burned to death, get chopped up, get beaten to death, get drowned to death, suicide somehow right away.
Do you guys know that like audio that's like making fun of of like true crime podcasts?
I quote it like way too often but it's just like her arms were cut off, her legs were cut off, her fingers were cut off, her eyes were cut out.
That's what that makes me think of.
Get locked up forever, get burned to death, get chopped up to death, get beaten to death, get drowned to death.
That's what I think of.
That's so stupid.
Um...
Let's see.
And you are not it!
Get chopped up everybody!
Good soup!
I see, the fun is over now.
I see.
Check the sweet potatoes that I'm cooking right now.
Oh, he's cooking!
Oh!
Imo!
Yakimo!
Can I have that?
I saw something.
Yakimo!
Oh, it's vibrating.
What do I do with it?
Yakimo!
Oh, I...
Hold on.
Phew!
I'm sending it back home!
Yakimo!
I'll pick it up at my apartment.
Hold on, maybe I can make it actually.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where I live, that's where I live.
Yakimo!
Okay.
Thank you, sir!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yakimo!
Oishii yakimo!
Yeah, I can't wait to have that later.
Yeah, yeah.
This is gonna be my snack later.
I wonder if these are actually making it.
Let's go check real quick.
He didn't say how many I couldn't have.
He just said, check them out.
And I'm a...
appreciator.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't think they made it.
No!
Sir, they're ghost...
They're ghost sweet potatoes.
What do I do?
He doesn't answer.
Okay.
Ooh, the lights are out.
I don't like that.
Oh, the lights are...
Hello?
Oh.
The landlord is going to find me at this rate.
Is that the landlord?
I can't see shit.
Oh, I can't go this way.
What's that?
Oh, an apple.
Wait.
Oh.
Uh.
Is he gonna find me?
Oh!
Let's take his stuff.
Key to room 201.
Maybe if I ring it and then...
Where do I run to?
Don't just sit there.
I don't know!
Yeah, I was thinking sit there and then run to the bathroom.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Open.
Even though I don't think I should be listening to the priest.
You know.
I could make his water really hot.
Where's the door he's talking about?
Uh.
It's so dark.
Where's that door?
We were talking about, guy.
Look he's bathing in like cold ass water.
Am I blind?
Under the wood.
Oh.
The most silent cardboard boxes ever.
Shh.
Oh.
Can I move this?
Oh, there we go.
This seems like a bad idea.
Here we go!
The worst idea ever.
I don't care if the guy's a priest.
If he tells me to go into the basement out of the bath...
Oh no, is this SCP that...
Eternal Staircase SCP?
Uh oh.
Guys.
SCP game.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
It's a game.
It's uh oh.
We're playing a different game now.
Oh.
That is the longest staircase.
No one would go in there.
Okay, Mina.
You're a smart girl.
You see this.
You see a rinkety bed.
You see a chain.
What do you do?
You turn around.
You don't go in there.
You don't go there.
I think you leave.
Alright, let's just see what happens.
Okay, she's probably gonna jump out and scare me.
I should've gone to the bathroom.
I'm gonna pee myself.
Probably.
What an awful smell.
What an awful everything, Mina.
Did someone use it?
What?
That sounds like a cat.
Okay.
Time to leave.
Something's still here.
Oh, there it is.
Just kidding.
What is here?
Awful smell.
What am I missing?
Back corner?
Here?
Corner?
Awful smell.
Oh, here it is!
What is that?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there it is.
Scissors.
It moved in my belly.
It is alive, even in this situation.
I will not let you die, no matter what.
I promise to protect you, my beloved baby.
I will do my best, so do your best, too.
I'm sorry.
I will not let them do as they please.
Oh my god.
The baby.
Is it me?
Am I the baby?
Uh oh.
I heard the door open.
You came.
Long ago, the landlord was captivated by a woman.
And that led to his obsessiveness, which ended with him locking her here in the basement.
At the time, the woman was pregnant.
But the landlord didn't know about it.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Eventually, unbeknownst to anyone, she gave birth to twins.
However, she died from blood loss during childbirth.
The woman was 24 years old.
The same age as you.
Um...
Actually, I'm 23.
I contacted my father.
After learning about what happened, the landlord shook with fear and contacted me.
Oh my god.
This is the birthplace of Solid Snake and Liquid Snake.
I gave the twins the names Toru and Elena.
And left them in the care of an orphanage.
I'm Elena!
Elena!
The name of the woman who gave birth and died here is Yoko.
The child of Yoko has just returned.
Oh my god.
The woman who died here, her name was Yoko!
The child of Yoko just came back to this village.
Maybe...
Toru.
Yoko's child came back?
Myna, you're stupid.
You grew so much, Elena...
Your real name is Yoko.
How do you know that?
I should have told you this sooner.
That is your real name.
I noticed it after seeing you working here.
I saw you working here and that is when I noticed it.
Yoko.
Your mother became a child and became the mother of a child.
Oh.
Yoko, your mother turned into a child.
Ubume began to haunt the landlord!
Let's go!
Wait, what?
Huh?
No, no, no.
I told the Akihimo man that I was going to be chopped to pieces.
In order to stop the haunting, the Ubume's child must be burned to death when they get to the age of when the Ubume died.
Who decided that?
Who?
Who made these rules?
That is the landlord's plan.
No, you called us here so that if one of us escaped, you'd have another.
I called your brother...
I called your brother, Toru, here to put an end to this.
No... I think you were like, if there's one child that doesn't show up, at least there's the other!
What?
He knows about the situation and accepted?
That is why you don't need to be the sacrifice.
And yet?
You must run away!
Oh, he's helping me, maybe?
Before the landlord finds you!
Okay, let's go together!
Priest!
Priest.
How are you so fa- Priest!
Priest!
Wait, my brother- wait!
There's- wait!
How'd you go?
These stairs are so fast!
Priest!
My breath!
Priest's cardio is a hobby.
For real!
One second, I'm gonna try and fix my YouTube again real quick.
Um, that's wild.
Um, oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to end the stream if my YouTube doesn't work?
Oh no!
Okay, I'll just- I'll just wait again.
Um, okay.
So, sneaking mission...
But we have to save my brother!
We have to get to room 201, maybe?
Oh, I'm scared.
I can't see anything.
How do I know if he'll see me or not?
Which one is the door to the ladies?
Okay, this is the men's one.
Oh, the ladies one is boarded up.
Okay, we have to go through this one.
Okay.
What's that goopy sound?
Is he in there?
Oh, do I have to go there?
Hello?
No,
you have to burn me!
Oh, it's loaded?
Uh oh.
Oh, wait, what's that?
Why is there a timer?
What's the big old timer up there for?
Oh my god.
Ah!
What?
Okay.
Huh?
Oh.
Clean!
Oh my god, what's going on?
Death.
This keeps painting death.
Time to clean, baby!
This is my job!
This is my living!
This is what I do!
I'm a maid!
Huh?
What happened?
I'm a maid!
Oh, what?
Oh, here, again.
What's that sound?
I'm a maid!
Wait, oh.
Oh.
Oh now... oh my gosh, they're filling up.
But...
Wait, I can't clean unless it's off.
Okay, I got it.
Oh my gosh!
Stop it!
Stop it this instant!
Where?
Stop at this instant!
Am I gonna live?
I can't tell!
How many do I need to do?
Uh-oh.
Can I leave?
Can I leave, please?
What?
More?
What do I...
What the hell?
Oh, a tear.
I see it, like, trying to come out the wall.
I see, like, a little bloopy coming out the wall.
No!
You shall not pass!
Yeah, we're scrubbing the ghost.
I saw it, like, standing through the walls at some point.
Oh, see?
You can see it sometimes.
Waiting its turn.
No!
Stop!
Wait, I didn't get to do it!
Wait!
Wait, no, no, that's not fair!
It bugged out on me!
Oh, over here, over here.
Oh!
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, no, no!
Not on my watch!
Oh my god, this should be, like, one of those cleaning commercials.
Like, I'm... I'm Mint Phantom, and today I introduce you to Phantom Cleanup!
Do you have a pesky ghost that just won't stop spraying...
Uh-oh.
Please, please, please, let me out.
I'm scared.
What?
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Uh...
Anything?
Am I missing one?
Here.
Uh...
Oh my god, oh my god!
Hey!
Chill out!
Uh... this side?
Okay, it's really hard to see when you're, like, glooping out the mirror, okay?
Stop!
Did I get it?
I think I'm too good at this.
Ghost is like...
Yeah, this ghost is nasty!
You're disgusting filthy!
Look at... look at all this soap all over the place.
We're doing the best job cleaning ever!
Oh, change the temperature?
Wait, what?
Oh, I see, I see.
Interesting.
We haven't had to do that.
Yeah, you can't get on these mirrors because they're too clean!
Oh.
Uh.
Change the temperature.
Wait!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
No!
I'm scared!
Why?
Uh oh.
I'm running.
I'm getting out of here.
Oh my god!
I think I died.
Give
me landlord, you freak!
Wait, what did that say?
Run away to the apartment.
Okay.
I'm running.
Don't
come looking for me.
Don't come looking for me.
My apartment?
Okay.
What's this?
There's a hole.
Wait, he moved my stuff.
Oh, I don't even have the key to 201.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Hide somewhere?
Um.
Let's hide somewhere.
What's going on in there?
Oh.
Uh.
See, this is our bug problem.
Oh.
See, I don't think she's trying to go after me.
I think she's trying to go after him.
She's helping me.
I think.
Actually, I'm not quite sure anymore.
Push the cabinet.
I can't see anything.
Push.
Oh.
She killed him.
Maybe not.
Hey.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear red cloud.
Maybe I shouldn't have gone to the front door.
I thought he was dead.
Oh.
Princess Carrie.
Hey.
Anybody gonna help me here?
Hey, brother.
Brother, you know it's me.
Brother.
Did I get the bottom?
This place seems way less rural.
In this, like, kind of way.
Like, see.
You see the tall buildings and stuff.
It doesn't look as rural as it seemed before.
No.
Not the bathhouse.
Okay.
I get it.
You keep carrying me.
Help.
Oh, wait.
I should say it in Japanese.
Help me.
Who is it?
This.
Oh, my God.
He's still going.
Oh, no.
He's dragging me over to the furnace.
He's gonna burn me.
My birthday.
Is that my birthday yet?
I'm not 24.
You're gonna make her more angry.
You're killing her child.
Why would that make her happy?
Oh, my God.
I'm seeing red.
He's just slowly scooting me in there.
Oh, my God.
Real bad end, huh?
This sucks.
No.
I am curious to know if this works though, right?
That looks like a head of hair.
Are you gonna look up at me?
Get ending one.
Oh, each ending has a different song.
This
is kind of awesome.
I like how Ali and Doki are right next to each other.
I love Whispersang.
Doki was mentioned twice?
Oh!
This is kind of awesome.
I'm gonna have to go back and see what the credit was.
I'm gonna have to go back and see...
Okay, that's it.
Banger alert.
I wanna hear the other ones too though.
But I think, even still, if I hear the other ones, this might be my favorite.
Even though I haven't heard the other ones, it's just because this is so up my alley.
I don't think I'm gonna go for the other endings.
I'm really sorry.
It's because I'm actually... quite tired.
I'm actually quite sleepy.
I didn't think this would be a 4 hour game.
I know I'm kinda slow with stuff because I like to joke around and run around and take my time, but...
I'm really sorry.
I'm really
sorry.
This already felt so much more polished than like...
Elmer.
Oh, thank you!
Toi Taira Elmer.
Thank you, I'll look it up later.
Oh, what's this?
I just started this job, but... I don't think I can continue anymore.
I want to quit.
Wait, it's starting us from here?
Is this the end?
Is it the landlord again?
I don't want to... Huh?
Huh?
Maina-san.
Are you there?
Oh, look!
It's her thing!
I never even noticed her little doll was there.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, huh?
Go to the basement of the bathhouse.
Huh?
Wait, don't I meet my brother down here?
Can I tell him?
Maybe the one thing that I didn't have?
Maybe...
Okay, there's gonna be a jump scare here.
I'm prepared!
Did you find out something about my sister?
No.
What's your name?
Now I can say...
Now I can say it!
It's Elena!
So you're Elena!
Really?
That's great!
The room 102 is where the priest lives, but...
He's letting me stay at the room.
So if something happens, come to room 102.
I'll be sure to help you.
Wait, maybe we...
can...
do it.
If I just skip through the dialogue, right?
If we just skip through the ending, right?
Oh, but I have to do all the cleaning stuff again.
Cleaning will be the longest part.
Yeah...
I think I remember in the first game, there was a chase sequence.
So I thought that was gonna happen again.
You could skip it.
Oh, no way.
Really?
Can I?
Come on.
Okay, I'm gonna trust you guys.
Should we talk to this guy again?
Sweet potato or is it liver?
Sweet potato sprout.
Sweet potato.
What did the man do to the girl?
He locked her up.
Last question.
What's gonna happen here?
I'm gonna run away!
The fun is over now.
Okay.
Check out my sweet potatoes.
Thank you!
Akimo!
Like, music started over, so it spooked me.
Wait, what's the key then to 201...
Wait...
This is three.
Huh?
Oh, it's this side.
I'm stupid.
Sorry.
What's the key to 201 then?
Can we use it now?
I kinda want to go see.
Let's see.
What if I do it now?
201.
This one.
I'm breaking in a... What?
This place is so nice!
This bastard!
You even have a real toilet!
The hardwood floors and everything!
Landlord's diary.
I chose to hire a girl.
She's young and beautiful.
That will bring in lots of customers.
Just seeing her lifts my mood.
The girl works hard.
She even sends flirtatious looks at me.
What to do?
Seems like she fell in love with me.
Maybe I'll call her by her first name from now on.
The young hire's name is written as Sakurako, but it's read as Yoko.
It's a name that's easy to call out.
Yoko is into me.
But still, weird guys get in between us.
Even though she's mine.
Yoko too.
Why is she letting those guys get their way with her?
I have an idea.
I should bring Yoko to the basement.
If she's down there, no other eyes but mine will ever see her.
I will let her know her place while she's in her early twenties.
It's been a while since I took her to the basement.
I should check up on her soon.
You don't even feed her?
I'm sure she understands what she is to me by now.
With this, she is truly my possession.
Yoko was dead.
Sorry, this is so...
Lying on the floor in a bloody mess.
It seems she was pregnant.
Who could possibly be the father?
Since when?
I won't forgive this.
What is that stain on the bathhouse wall?
Who is screaming at the bathhouse?
I can't stop hearing a woman scream endlessly.
I think I'm going crazy.
Even after closing time, I sometimes see a person's shadow.
But no one is there.
Who is it?
The black shadow chased me.
I had a monk perform a cleansing ritual on me, but there was no point in doing that.
The ghost keeps coming after me.
Please forgive me.
I didn't do anything wrong.
According to the monk, an ubume is haunting me.
It seems that there is a way to get rid of the curse, but it is not possible to do it the right way.
Is it not time yet?
Is it really fine if I let the monk handle this?
I can't stand this every day.
The priest says I understand my suffering.
I have to do something.
Is there nothing that can help me a moment sooner?
Hurry, hurry.
I must end this curse.
I'll call for her for that purpose.
No more waiting on the monk.
I'll do it myself.
And I got...
a tile.
Ew.
This place is so fancy.
No vtubers in here?
Okay.
There's multiple tiles for collectibles.
I see.
I think I saw someone in chat did mention that you had to get all the tiles to I guess get the best ending?
Is that what that means?
But we'll still try for this other ending.
And then for anyone who's curious about the last ending, you can probably just find it on YouTube.
You can just find it on YouTube.
Okay, so we'll do this part and then we'll skip the minigame.
La la la.
La la la la.
So, what was it?
102, right?
It's 102, right?
The longest basement ever in the world.
Yeah, 102.
Okay.
I'm sure if I run over there, there will be like a little arrow on it, but still.
I thought...
Okay, this might be spoilers for the previous game, but I guess because it's you know, off of Steam it doesn't really matter anymore.
But I almost could have sworn that the priest was in on it too before.
Like that used to be the case.
Alright, we read that.
Okay, I hear him.
Yeah, they were in cahoots, wasn't it?
That was the case in the old game.
Oh, hello.
Oh.
You grew up so much, Elena.
Yeah, thank you.
And then run away.
Okay.
I'm coming with you.
The child was locked in the cave.
Yeah, there was a cave, wasn't there?
Or something.
Hmm.
I'm thinking right now that the priest is the father.
And that's why he wants to help out his kids.
He's like, I couldn't protect Yoko, but I can protect my children.
They changed the plot quite a bit.
Yeah.
Okay, so now...
we go to the bubbly.
I don't know why, but the water right here looks like a video.
Like it looks almost real.
It's kind of freaky.
Ew,
I just licked my mic.
Alright, how do I skip a minigame?
Guys?
Guys, how do I skip the minigame?
Oh, it's open.
Oh, I can't go back inside.
I have to go into the water.
Oh my goodness.
That's a nice little mechanic, I guess.
That's nice.
Alright, to 102!
Alright,
to 102!
I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm
leaving...
There it is, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It lights up.
Perfect.
What's happening?
Oh my god, what's...
I'm fighting the old man!
Yeah, kick his ass!
Wait, what?
Did he catch you before you made it to the door?
I'm confused!
But this is also a different ending.
Oh wait!
Wait, what?
Oh!
Haha!
Huh?
Oh, brother!
Brother, what happened?
I'm sorry I couldn't get you at the door.
Yeah, you should be.
Have you guys seen...
Okay, this is so... sorry.
Have you guys seen the Lion King, the new Lion King movie trailer?
And I think it's like, it's the Mufasa prequel, right?
And in the trailer, one of the...
I think it... I don't know which...
If it's Mufasa or Scar, I don't know.
But he goes, I've always wanted a brother.
And then they repeat it again and he goes, I've always wanted a brother.
Yeah, apparently there's a new Lion King, like, the IRL, whatever, live action movie coming out.
But if you go listen to it, he goes, I've always wanted a brother.
It's so funny.
I can't stop thinking about it lately.
Sorry, okay, I just wanted to break that up because I've been thinking about it this whole time.
I'm happy that you reached out for my help.
I was surprised to learn that I had a twin sister.
Oh my god, wait, the place is on fire!
Brother, I'm behind you!
It's actually...
It's actually quite nice to know that I have a sibling, although I'm not used to it yet.
Brother, I'm behind you!
Half a month ago, I received a call from the priest.
He told me about Yoko, about the past, and about you.
He told me everything.
Even about the way to break the curse.
This is what I need to do.
Wait, what are you talking about?
I thought of it as my mission.
Wait, brother!
I've always wanted a brother.
That's why I'm here in this village, not because the priest called me.
No, no, no.
I came here on my own vol...
Oh, brother!
Whoa!
Wait, brother!
I think we're in trouble.
We need to get away from these plants.
I came here on my own volition.
I didn't expect to meet you, though.
Brother, I think we gotta get out of here.
I'm sorry for dragging you into this.
You didn't do anything, brother.
What do you mean, Saigo?
No, no, brother!
I'm glad I got to see you in the end.
Wait, in the...
If I know the tablets...
Is that how we save a brother?
Oh, that's right.
I'll give the seal.
I need to leave soon.
Where are you going?
No, brother!
Brother, no!
Brother!
Brother, where are you going?
Brother, don't go in there.
Brother, no!
Oh my god, he's so chill!
He's walking into those flames like such a badass!
Brother, no!
Oh!
I see.
Oh.
So what you're saying...
Is that a spirit?
Or a ghost?
Was haunting the bathhouse?
And the curse?
The sacrifice was needed?
Is that...
Toru-san became that sacrifice?
And Toru-san became that sacrifice?
So that's what it is.
Is that correct?
Is that what you're going to tell your lawyers?
You do know that in Japan, it's guilty before innocent?
Okay, okay.
Who was it that was telling such a story to you?
Who, you ask?
What do you mean?
What does that mean?
Oh, what the hell is that?
Huh?
Why did I pull that out?
By the way, did I show you my stick?
It was hidden in my omamori.
Yo, the bathhouse got cooked.
Was it an umbilical cord?
Oh, we get like a cutscene.
The building is still on fire.
Yeah, it's even still on fire.
That's where all the furniture flew around.
That's where we saw grandma.
Oh, I'm so nostalgic right now.
Good times, yeah.
We have been when it wasn't.
Which was all the time.
Oh, is that the bathroom with the squatty toilet?
Oh, good times.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, that's the boiler.
Is she going to jump out of there?
Mom!
Don't do it, mom!
Mom.
Mom!
I'm scared of you, mom.
Oh, there she is.
Is she shutting the door?
She's like, goodnight.
Ending 2.
Wait, what?
Oh, this is the second ending.
Song.
I always come back.
I like how the assets are like clipping in and out even in the ending.
Nah, the first song was so much better.
Look up the best ending.
I will, yeah.
It's not bad.
Why is Doki Bird on here twice?
Like, you guys were right.
She was there twice.
It's not bad.
I just like the first one better.
I missed the celebration yesterday because I was busy.
No worries!
Thank you for the super chat!
Sorry, I didn't get to read the rest.
My YouTube is broken.
Will your ashes be scattered to the heartless sea?
I just saw your dono.
David, thank you.
Doki Doki.
This song is pretty good.
Oh, yeah?
I do like going around the...
I kind of wish...
I mean, I know like...
This is probably like an asset or whatever.
I wish there was like some burnt parts of the...
Like, you know, you see the fridge.
You see the...
The burnt table.
I wish there was stuff like that.
Is that someone's birthday?
Wait, who's birthday?
Happy birthday!
Don't scatter me, please.
Scatter ashes to the heartless sea.
No, you don't scatter the ashes.
You rub them all over your face.
Come here, ashes!
Oh, this is a short song, even.
Make them into diamonds.
Luckily, it didn't take so much to...
Get to this ending.
I do really appreciate that they allow you to skip the...
Skip the minigame.
I guess the final boss.
But I'm curious.
I never saw any other tiles.
I'm very curious where they are now.
You know?
I never saw a single one.
And I kind of like walked around a bunch of places.
And kind of like...
Sniffed around a bunch.
There's one on the supporter scoreboard.
Maybe just because I didn't know where to look for them.
Maybe.
Maybe they didn't have like a little...
Little arrow above it, you know?
So I just didn't think to look.
How many are there?
I'm curious if anybody knows.
Because I definitely don't want to go through the whole game all over again.
One is answering...
Sweet potato man's questions correctly.
What?
Oh, maybe I needed to actually move the emu.
The sweet potato.
And it would be buried under the sweet potato?
Oh my god.
Yeah, this wasn't highlighted in yellow.
Yeah, yeah.
They revealed the tile at the very end...
For replayability.
Basic game design.
Actually, they only revealed it...
Actually, if I had never gone to the bedroom...
I never would have known.
Hmm.
Maybe it was four.
So one in the...
Yeah, it would have to be four, right?
Because it was square.
So one at the shooting range.
One in his bedroom.
One...
Oh, they let you start here.
Yeah.
One at the emu.
And then...
Another.
Somewhere.
Another one in a mysterious location.
I like how the hair like...
Slips off of you.
And that's how you start this part.
It's kind of neat.
I do like that.
What is this?
Oh!
Gross!
Oh, we have...
What?
It's our umbilical...
It was in there!
That was pretty insane compared to the OG and other Chilla's games.
At least you got to shoot Doki.
Goodnight!
Oh my god, it's an umbilical cord!
And then we have his room key.
Neat!
It's so cool that they give you this stuff.
Like right here.
So, hold on.
I want to go quit real quick.
And then if we continue...
Oh, so it does...
Okay.
But obviously we would start at day one if we wanted to get the...
That...
Last ending.
Let me see.
I wonder if I can find like a...
Oh wait.
No, my YouTube is broken.
Guys, I would watch it...
But my YouTube is literally...
I can't...
It's not loading anything.
Even now...
I'm going to quit the game and see if it helps.
Maybe it's like... Maybe the game is possessing my computer.
Restart my browser?
Yeah, let's try that.
Because otherwise, how am I going to quit...
The stream?
How am I going to end the stream?
Uh oh.
I think it might be Firefox.
Firefox is...
Not opening back up.
Uh oh.
Uh...
Oh!
It opened!
It's loaded!
Okay, let's see.
Bathhouse...
Ending 3.
I want to see if I can...
Oh, 30 minutes.
Oh wait.
This one says...
All endings.
Hold on.
Let me see if there's someone talking over it.
Okay, no, no, no.
I think we're good.
Let me see if I can find...
Um...
Let's see if I can find...
The final ending.
Okay, here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Give me a second.
Let's uh...
I'm going to...
We'll watch it on here.
Hold on, let me pull my chat back up to...
Give me one second.
What is with the weird comments that are just like...
People's names.
Usually spam comments are just like...
Oh yeah, they're paying for like this.
But like, I don't understand it.
When it's like just the names.
Oh wait, that's not what I meant to do.
Alright, this is the last ending.
Uh...
Courtesy of Iridos Gaming.
Thank you.
Oops, hold on.
There we go.
Bots are so weird.
Usually if it's just like...
Oh yeah, come to my website for sexy time.
Like that would make sense.
But this doesn't make any sense to me.
Uh...
Um...
I heard it's to trigger real names through blacklist.
But like...
Some people just have that as their YouTube.
You know what I mean?
Like some people's...
Their name is their YouTube name.
I don't know.
Alright, let's watch the last ending.
Right here.
Okie dokie.
Oh, sorry for the white border.
Hold on.
It's gonna annoy me too.
Wait.
Uh... yeah.
There we...
Go.
Good enough.
There.
Ok, let's watch.
Okie.
Oh.
Oh, we have the umbilical cord.
Do we give it to our mom?
Mom, look.
It's my... It's us.
Hot bath house is in your area.
Mom, look.
It's us.
Oh.
There you go.
My mom...
Is cute.
Aww.
The umbilical cord.
I'm...
Oh.
Bye, mom.
It does that so curse.
What do you mean?
The graphics are...
Actually, they're probably playing this on high.
Or on, like, ultra.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I only played it on high.
But the graphics look so much better than, like...
What's happening?
What is this music?
Let's wrap it up.
What?
Oh my god.
Look.
Our priest.
Seek your Sam.
What?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
He's just an old man.
He can't kick his ass easy.
Old man fight.
Oh my god.
If only this was on top of the bathhouse.
Can you imagine?
That would be so awesome.
Oh.
That was it?
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I should have gone to the police much earlier.
I just...
I had hoped the landlord would repent for what he had done by getting haunted.
When I knew that Yoko was haunting him.
I felt that she wanted to get her revenge.
Yes.
And that revenge was her only wish.
So I thought it would be best for everyone involved if things were left to run its course.
It's been 24 years!
If he didn't feel bad the first time, why would he feel bad 20 years later?
I was just an observer of what happened.
Even the gods told me not to intervene.
I don't believe that.
It was what I told myself.
I was deciding the gods will on my own.
But I was wrong.
The gods will was not there.
Only Yoko's will.
Yoko didn't really want revenge the most.
As a mother, Yoko was just deeply concerned about her children.
Awwww.
I was just thinking about my children.
Even after her death, Yoko was trying to protect her children.
She was a wonderful mother.
Okay, that's why she spooked me so much?
Yoko really wanted to see her children.
She harassed me in the bathtub!
Elena, thank you.
You saved Yoko, your mother, and me.
You're Yoko?
Thank you very much.
Please live on with your mother in your heart.
What about my brother?
Oh, mother!
Brother!
I've always wanted a brother.
It's all over, isn't it?
I heard everything from the priest.
And I came here on my own will to break...
Break?
Yoko...
No, mom's curse.
And I thought my mission was to release Ubume into the world.
Well, as long as the curse can be broken, I didn't care what would happen in this world.
Is what I thought at first.
But I was wrong!
You're amazing!
You didn't know anything, but you solved it!
I don't... okay.
I'm not used to saying it, but I feel proud that you're my sister.
Hey!
What are you going to do from now on?
Find a job?
I don't know.
I live in another village that is a little far from here.
There's nothing there, but the people are really nice.
Let me come with you!
Everyone here is rude and terrible!
I hope this village burns down!
Do you want to come live with me?
Oh, what if you say no?
You have a decision.
You have a choice.
Let's go together then.
But also, brother, why are you a wanted man?
Why are you a wanted criminal?
Could you please explain that to me?
Before I go live in your house?
Please explain the signs, brother.
Can you tell me why you are a wanted criminal?
Brother.
Please.
Okay, bye everybody.
You can't even wave.
Oh, mom!
Oh, mom.
Oh my god, brother is the slowest driver ever.
Alright, brother.
Step on it.
Wow!
Bye, you weirdos.
See you never.
Oh my god.
Where is the mom?
Oh, sorry.
How do I get rid of these pictures?
How do I get rid of this?
Oh, my god.
I can't say...
Oh, gosh.
Oh, god.
There we
go.
They're related.
Oh,
gosh.
Don't look at my...
I don't even know what's in my recommended...
You're gonna see airport and cozy jazz music, okay?
Please, stop judging me.
This is why I have multiple, multiple, what's it called, YouTubes.
Anyway, woo!
That was fun!
That was good.
I liked the old man fight.
Give me a second, I might move us over.
Here.
There we go.
Give me a second also, let me...
Let's do...
I don't talk for too long, because I'm tired.
But I just don't want to talk in the void.
Woo!
That was fun!
I hope you guys enjoyed the stream.
There was something I was gonna say and I don't remember what.
I do plan on streaming tomorrow.
Sorry, no schedule.
I don't think I'll be able to stream on Saturday.
Actually, maybe early Saturday.
Mmm...
I think I'll move Metal Gear to Sunday though.
Gabriel, thanks for the gift!
I'm tri-princess, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Thanks, it's fun!
Thank you!
Your menu's outdated.
Um, actually it's not.
Because that's the last episode of the podcast.
So...
It's the only thing...
Actually, let me add my 3.0, huh?
Let me at least add that too.
Let's see.
Let's see...
There we go.
I have two things on the menu.
That and that.
Uh...
Welcome to Mammoth Ship!
I'm sorry if I said your name wrong.
Sorry, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Can't wait to see you at Bolt Mint!
Yeah!
I'll be...
I'll be able to stream something earlier in the day.
And then perform that night.
So...
I should be able to stream Saturday as well.
And then Sunday will be Metal Gear.
Star Sticks!
Welcome to Mammoth Ship!
Thank you!
Yeah...
It's Vmuse next weekend.
Yes!
So, concert back-to-back weekend.
And...
Take care of your voice after the busy day.
Thank you!
Uh...
Sorry, my brain is all tired now.
I wish I could show you guys that...
That Lion King trailer.
But I'm afraid Disney will bonk me.
And I can't...
I can't...
I can't afford that.
I can't afford another strike on my channel.
Thank you!
Are you watching?
Dan the Dan.
It's so spooky.
What's that?
Oh!
I saw...
The... Actually...
The Creepy Nuts song was...
Was recommended to me.
But I haven't watched...
I didn't know anything about it.
I don't know anything about it.
Is it scary?
Is it actually creepy?
Is it actually spooky?
Hmm...
So excited for the concert.
Thank you, Tony!
Thank you!
It's spooky cool.
Hmm...
It's crazy.
It's wacky.
Hmm...
I look into it.
I've been slowly, slowly, slowly getting through...
Girls Band Cry.
I'm like on episode 4.
Slowly, slowly.
When I can.
So...
I've been watching that.
Especially because I saw...
You know, I saw them at Anisama.
So...
Um...
And then I also went to like a...
A thing they had at...
Laforet.
No, sorry.
Not...
Atore.
Have fun and come back for live entertainment.
Thank you!
Has she held the yogurt that makes you cry?
Yes.
Yes, she has held the yogurt that makes you cry.
I don't even know if it's airing this season.
I...
Is it...
Is ReZero this season?
Or am I crazy?
Yes.
Yeah, I gotta start that.
First episode just aired.
If it wasn't so late, I would watch it.
Oh, okay.
Aired yesterday.
It's an hour and a half!
Oh, Lizumaki.
Can't wait for you to get through my feed during the last few episodes with Absolute Crazy.
It's so wild.
Before Girls Band cry.
Okay, I have to watch.
You know what?
Good.
Good thing they made it in an hour and a half.
Because they've been...
ReZero's been gone for so long!
Like, please!
At least they gave us that.
Over the Garden Wall when?
Probably closer to Halloween.
Even though...
Did you guys see that there was going to be...
Did you see David Hayter tweet?
That is so vague.
I don't know.
I have seen him tweet before, yeah?
There's like an Over the Garden Wall 10th anniversary thing that they're doing.
But they're doing it on November 2nd.
And I'm like...
What?
Why?
Why are you doing it on November 2nd?
When it's a...
When it's a Halloween...
It takes place on a Halloween night!
So...
Let me go see David Hayter.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
David Hayter...
He was in the booth today.
Is that the one?
Playing a role I've not played since...
What does that mean?
New Guyver?
I don't think it's new lines for Delta.
Unless it's like...
Unless it's like stuff for...
But nobody...
Like controls and stuff.
Guyver would be bonkers.
Oh my gosh.
Maddie and I just wouldn't shut up about Guyver.
At MGS Con.
Because like...
We were just saying how...
You know... I mean David Hayter is still an attractive guy.
But like...
Back then even he was so...
He was a Hollywood heartthrob.
He was so cute.
He was so...
So like... Oh my god.
He could have been up there with like...
Leonardo DiCaprio.
Okay.
I'm gonna go.
Because it's almost been five hours.
And that means I've been streaming for like...
Well I've been on stream.
For like...
Like eight hours today.
So I'm tired.
Probably will take it easy the next two days.
So I can also get some rest from my trip.
And also for the concert.
So...
I'm still not sure what I'll do tomorrow.
But I'll figure it out.
Satisfactory playthrough.
Win.
What?
Oh.
Satisfactory?
No, no.
Not my type of game.
Um...
Not really my type of game.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Maybe someday.
I don't know.
But...
Not anytime soon.
Yeah.
Um...
I do have like a lot of spooky games.
That I do want to do this month though.
So...
Sorry if spooky games are not your thing.
But...
Spooky games are on the menu baby.
So...
Gonna be probably doing...
A good bit of spooky games.
I have another collab next week.
A spooky game collab.
So...
Yeah.
Uh...
Probably.
Not probably.
We'll have that.
But...
Sometime.
Yeah.
Okay.
Otsumito.
I will see you guys When I see you.
Have a wonderful day.
Wonderful night.
Whatever time it is for you.
And...
Itterashai.
I'll see you later.
Bye bye.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
See you.
Bye bye.